Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten,
Mein name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle zur ausgabe nummer fünfundachtzig
und heute hat mich der weg nach göttingen geführt warum naja
ich habe ja hier in der reihe schon mehrfach über die einzelnen komponenten unseres sonnensystems gesprochen wir waren virtuell schon beim merkur beim maß bei der venus
auch das saturn system wurde schon durch flogen jüngst auch nochmal der pluto abgeklopft,
aber eins der elefant im raum sozusagen er hat bisher immer gefehlt nämlich die sonne und ja deswegen führt mich der weg zum institut für astrophysik hier an der universität,
in göttingen und begrüße meinen gesprächspartnern volker botmar hallo schönen guten tag.
Ja gleichfalls schönen guten tag.
Herr botmar die sonne bestimmt ihr leben habe ich so den eindruck mehr als das von uns allen kann man das so sagen.
Ja zeitlich kann man das schon so sagen durch die viele arbeit die wir gott sei dank haben in der forschung an der erforschung der sonne.
Fangen wir doch mal mit ihnen an wie wie sind sie denn zur wissenschaft gekommen war das so schon immer gewinnen oder war es eher zufallen sie wollten eigentlich friseur werden.
Na ja das war so dass ich während der schulzeit gerne physik unterricht physikunterricht teilgenommen habe das liegt.
Mit sicherheit auch an bestimmten lehrern die mich motiviert haben ganz klar dann war ich natürlich,
begeistert als kind die staat der apollo mission zu verfolgen die mondlandung und dann habe ich schon.
In welchem alter.
Acht an meinem achten geburtstag war der start,
das bleibt hängen,
zusätzlich zu den geschenken natürlich und dann hatte ich also relativ früh doch den wunsch vor beginn der oberstufe schon physik zu machen physik oder geschichte geschichte war auch ein bisschen offen noch.
Aber physik leistungskurs es und dann.
Habe ich auch direkt mit dem studium der physik angefangen und zwar in göttingen göttingen ja eine sehr gute tradition besaß viele nobelpreisträger.
Ausreichend nah und weit weg von zu hause für das studium.
Und dann war ich natürlich immer raumfahrt interessiert aber das ziel war erstmal das studium zu schaffen und.
Als ich die gelegenheit hatte mir eine diplomarbeit,
auszusuchen oder zu wählen angenommen zu werden habe ich festgestellt da es gibt ja das institut für physik an dem kann man sich mit den satelliten daten des äußeren magnetfeldes beschäftigen.
Und dann habe ich eine kombination gewählt aus analyse von satelliten daten für sogenannte magnetische stürme.
Da bin ich da hab ich mein diplom gemacht zu dem thema magnetische steil stürme.
Welche phänomene bemerkt man am erdboden in welchem breiten und dann,
es war ein sehr großes ereignis dass ich mein diplom im jahr neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig gemacht habe und in dem jahr im märz neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig gab es eine der letzten riesig großen sonnenflecken gruppen auf der sonne,
und es hat im märz neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig ein super sturm gegeben auf der sonne der zum beispiel zum,
stromausfall in kanada in québec für viele stunden geführt hat.
Die konsequenzen sind sehr sehr weitreichend also ich habe dann halt mein diplom gemacht und kurz in dem monat nach dem.
Sonnenstürme und mein professor hat damals.
Mir eine positionsarbeit angeboten also quasi schon probiert und ich hatte noch mal die gelegenheit einer seiner letzten doktoranden zu sein vielleicht der letzte und dann,
kann ich mich gut an die frage und themenstellung erinnern können sie herr boot mal nicht mal rausfinden wann es auf der sonne stürmt und wann es auf der erde zu gravierenden konsequenzen kommt.
Und dann habe ich mich auch angesetzt im institut für geo physik und angefangen und doch recht schnell gemerkt dass ich ohne spezifische kenntnisse des treiber aus der sonne und der sonnenwind ist forschungs- nicht weiterkommen.
Komme und hab dann kontakt zum max-planck-institut für damals noch ironie heute sonnensystem,
forschung in katlenburg lindau jetzt in göttingen aufgenommen und hab 'ne,
produktionsstelle von max blank angeboten bekommen und zwar an den zur analyse der sonnenwind daten der helios mission.
Und dann war ich quasi in guten händen dort konnte ich lernen was erzeugt was er hat magnetische stürme.
Der sonnenwind verschiedene parameter geschwindigkeit dichte temperatur vor allem das magnetfeld deshalb von der sonne nach außen konvertiert und das dann auf das erdmassiv nietfeld einwirkt,
und zu strömen führt indem im magnetfeld selbst dann geladene teilchen beschleunigt werden.
Die dann zu polarlichtern führen die aber ursprünglich also der sonnenwind wie es vielfach im internet.
Fast überall falsch steht durchströmt nicht das magnetfeld und es,
strömen auch keine sonnenwind teilchen direkt an den polen in die erdatmosphäre sondern der sonnenwind im wesentlichen umströmt das magnetfeld kann aber,
bei in dem moment wo der sonnenbank nietfeld entgegengesetzt gerichtet ist zum magnetfeld zu strömen,
im äußeren magnetfeld in der magnetismus fähre führen und auf der nacht seite sondern abgefunden seite elektrische felder,
hervorrufen indem die dort gefangenen teilchen die auch zum großen teil aus der erdatmosphäre selbst stamm beschleunigt werden und dann in die pole reinlaufen die elektronen kilowatt gold energien und die polarlichter auslösen man,
heute dass etwa die stürme durch die connection feld linien verschmelzung,
zusammenkommen unterschiedlicher magnetfeld richtung.
Des magnetfeldes auf der nacht seite des geschieht im abstand von etwa sechs ertragen radius haben wir.
Sechstausend kilometer.
Heutzutage bei starken stürmen die letzten messungen zeigen dass das sogar bei vier ertragen passiert ja und.
So im mittelpunkt ihrer arbeit dann auch.
War der ursprüngliche ansatzpunkt der dann aber erweitert wurde auf,
phänomene der sonnenwind ist also mein betreuer der doktorarbeit der herr professor spenden war damals leiter des deutschen plasma instrumentes auf den helios unten die vierundsiebzig und sechsundsiebzig gestartet wurden und,
im grunde genommen würde ich sagen ausgelöst wurden durch die,
mission auf allen apollo missionen hat man also folien,
auf dem mond aufgebracht noch vor der amerikanischen flagge bei apollo übrigens um die bestzeit zu optimieren hat dann sonnenwind teilchen da der mund keine atmosphäre besitzt eingesammelt wieder mit zur erde gebracht analysiert.
Also helios waren deutsch-amerikanische billaterales projekt und hatte als zielsetzung die erkundung des raumes zwischen sonne und erde und der ist wie wir heute wir natürlich wissen.
Ausgefüllt mit sonnenwind muss man dazu sagen dass der,
parker neunzehnhundertachtundfünfzig der erste war also ein bisschen vorher in den jahren vorher gab's in göttingen berühmten astrophysiker den ludwig biermann der anhand von kometen beobachtung festgestellt hat es gibt zwei schweife einmal den,
stopp schweif und einmal den,
plasma oder gar schweif der bläulich leuchtet und er hat schon vermutet dass das durch einen partikel strom der von der sonne kommt ausgelöst wird und,
halb geschwindigkeiten abgeschäfft von einigen hunderten von kilometer pro sekunde.
Und herr becker hat dann aufgrund der hydrodynamik eine theorie aufgestellt dass aus der sonnenabend affäre stetigen strom geladener teilchen ausströmen muss hat ihm den namen sonnenwind gegeben und der ist dann erstmals mit der russischen logik.
Mit den ludwig sondern gemessen worden eine sonde hat nämlich den nicht den mond getroffen,
ärgerlicherweise und ist dann übers ziel hinausgeschossen für uns gut hat also teichen messungen geliefert aber man konnte nicht eindeutig klären ob wirklich die sonne die quelle war und da gibt's noch ein bisschen,
differenzen in der wissenschaftlichen community und definitiv neunzehnhundertzweiundsechzig marina zwei mit auch personen die ich persönlich kenne frau neugebauer die als als,
sozusagen die leiterin des plasma experiments war da hat man den sonnenwind gemessen und im weiteren sinne dann mit apollo und dann,
mit den helios den sonnenwind im ganzen bereich zwischen sonne und erde und zwar bis zur dichtesten im dichtesten abstand von,
ungefähr zweiundvierzig millionen kilometer das entspricht so der ernährung des merkur an die sonne mit temperaturen von fünfhundert grad und ich hatte eben dann das große.
Glück sozusagen diesen datenschutz zu haben also die sonnenwind daten über diesen bereich auswerten zu können um dann sozusagen herauszufinden welcher sonnenwind macht bei der erde eigentlich die großen stürme.
Das heißt da sind sie eigentlich sozusagen über die beschäftigung mit mit dem magnetfeld und eigentlich der fokussierung zunächst einmal auf die physik mehr oder weniger über umwege in die sonne geschleudert worden und bei dem thema dann gelandet.
So also physik wollte ich halt machen und,
insgesamt physik und nicht nur spezialfall physik und musik ist eigentlich bedingt daraus ergibt sich daraus weil göttingen sehr lange tradition in den untersuchung der solaris frischen beziehung besitzt,
und zwar geht das zurück was ganz wichtig zu wissen ist denke ich mal auf herrn gaus alexander von humboldt,
deren systematischen messungen des magnetfeldes und gaus hat dann auch schon als,
erkannt dass es gewisse schwankungen gibt die man anschaulicher weise mit kompass nadeln feststellen kann oder mit messinstrumente wie sie magnete meter genannt werden.
Die ich übrigens auch während der studentenzeit habe ich einen versuch betreut zur messung des magnetfeldes und da gibt es systematische schwankungen und gaus hat schon.
Erkannt dass die externe ursprung sein müssen hat die die rätselhafte schrift der natur genannt das ist der sonnenwind,
wie wir es heute wissen.
Gut wir stürzen uns sozusagen schon voll drauf aber dann nehme ich mal die vorlage an der stelle auf denn ich würde mich ganz gerne erstmal so historisch der der sonne widmen
ist ja nun mal ein sehr auffälliges objekt bevor man sich über die situation der planeten so im klaren war
die rolle der sonne war irgendwie naheliegend in gewisser hinsicht nicht nur weil sie so groß ist sondern einfach jeder die wirkung halt unmittelbar
spüren kann und von daher hat sich die menschheit auch schon immer intensiv mit der sonne beschäftigt
ein paar naheliegende und vielleicht nicht ganz so naheliegende theorien dafür aufgebaut und würden sie denn sagen dass eigentlich so die erste nennenswerte wissenschaftliche erkenntnis gewonnen wurde darüber
was denn nun eigentlich die sonne ist und was sie welche rolle sie spielt.
Also grundsätzlich ist es so dass der mensch natürlich die sonne,
schon seit ewigen zeiten im visier hat also man sieht bei sonnenuntergang wenn man auf die sonne gucken darf wegen der atmosphäre dazwischen sodass das nicht schädlich für die augen ist gibt's natürlich sonnenflecken beobachtung dunklen flecken,
gehen.
Und dann hat es einen großen schritt natürlich gegeben durch die entdeckung oder entwicklung des teleskop.
Wo man natürlich auch bei den beobachtungen aufpassen muss deswegen werden die wird die sonne dann im allgemeinen auf dem blatt,
papier zum beispiel abgebildet damit man nicht direkt reinguckt gab es seit galileo und anderen wissenschaftlern.
Hat man also mit der mit der entwicklung der teleskope die sonnenflecken systematisch beobachten können.
Aufzeichnungen können was er immer in der wissenschaft ein ganz entscheidender schritt ist dass wir auch bei herrn gozo mit dem magnetfeld das ich muss erstmal,
ein instrument entwickeln dass ich,
nominiere kalibrieren um damit dann über einen längeren zeitraum dedizierte messungen machen zu können die ich dann anschließend auswerten kann sind zum beispiel die messung von,
störung des magnetfeldes vom gaus so gut aufgeschrieben dass ich alle paar minuten wert habe und heutzutage sagen,
da waren polarlichter der schreibt er auch selber und man kann also magnetische stürme sogar in den jahren achthundertneununddreißig vierzig heutzutage analysieren und weiß das war der sonnenwind,
das hat dann von wolf.
Im achtzehnten jahrhundert die einführung der sonnenflecken relativ zeit gegeben und man hat dann anhand des vergleichs des der sonnenflecken mit polarlichtern die.
Diesen zusammenhang hat man festgestellt hohe sonderaktion vitalität polarlichter hat man also angefangen eine beziehung zwischen sonne und erde zu vermuten da gibt's irgendwas.
Es gab sogar von dem einen franzosen vorstellungen das schon wolken von teilchen von der sonne zur erde fliegen achtzehnhundertsechzig home achtundsiebzig um etwa.
Und dann hat natürlich carrington systematisch beobachtungen gemacht.
Durch ein großes sonnentälern korb.
Noch davor beobachtung geliefert hat das war natürlich weiß ich das wissen die meisten das achthundert neunundfünfzig der stärkste jemals in der geschichte beobachtete sonnenstürme stattgefunden hat der kevin event.
Starke licht blitze sogenannte flair auf der sichtbaren sonnenscheibe die mit magnetfelder die ja mit wann geht feldern bedeckt.
Ist da komme ich gleich dazu wichtiger aspekt blitzt er in den sonnenflecken auf und,
zwei tage später starke stürme nordlicht polar-licht aktivität,
es gibt ja auch südlicher als polar-licht aktivität funkenschlag im telegraph anleitungen und so weiter dort wurden gerade die bahnlinien.
Gelegt in england und man hat sich dann beim bau verständigt über die telegraph anleitung und heute wissen wir große sonnenstürme gab es zu der zeit die stärksten die wir registriert haben.
Bis heute und danach nach carrington entdeckung so eine sonnenstürme,
deren möglichen konsequenzen auf die erde kann man dann so weitergehen und sagen ja okay zu der zeit dann auch die maxwell-gleichung elektromagnetische feldstärke wichtiger aspekt war sicherlich,
die.
Entwicklung des spektrum mit dem man spektrum des sonnenlichtes erstellen konnte und auch durch die verschiebung der spektral linien auf das magnetfeld der sonne schließen konnte seemann effekt das hat.
Henry entdeckt etwa neunzehnhundertzehn rum.
Damit wusste man die sonne besitzt ein magnetfeld und die fraunhofer linie natürlich im spektrum des sonnenlichtes die absorptionsrate linien aus denen man dann auf die chemische zusammensetzung der sonne schließen kann,
auch darauf dass es bestimmte atome in,
hochmotorisierten zustand gibt man hat die grüne corona linie bei sonnenfinsternis beobachtet eisen vierzehn fach juni ziert das sind zustände atomare die man auf der erde,
nicht hat hat auch auf elemente wie das corona geschlossen die es nicht gibt weil man gar nicht damit gerechnet hat dass in der sonne wäre in der äußeren sonnatg mosquito wäre.
Über der sichtbaren scheibe ist die fotos fähre eine heiße corona ist und heißt deswegen weil die,
atome eben in so einem hohen sanierungs- zustand sind eisen vierzehn eisen sechzehn.
Da mal kurz einhaken darf das heißt eigentlich kann man sagen am anfang als das ganze nur eine optische beobachtung war,
so seine liebe mühe hatte die sonne überhaupt erstmal optisch einzufangen ob der helligkeit war eigentlich so primär das erste was man erstmal weggenommen hat,
ja ist hell aber hat dunkle stellen,
und die wandern auch das heißt damit war so ein so ein erstes mysterium im prinzip auch schon mal geboren was es zu erforschen gab aber man hat halt noch nicht so die mittel und so im neunzehnten jahrhundert kann man im prinzip alles auf einmal so diese ganze,
von magnetismus elektromagnetismus also auf der erde wie dann eben auch im zusammenspiel mit der sonne das kann dann irgendwie zeitgleich und passend dazu dann eben auch noch dieses ereignis was
dann wahrscheinlich alle komplett mental ionisiert hat bin ich mal an.
Wobei die beobachtung dabei wissenschaft macht dann stellt man ja immer fest dass man es mit einer das dinge sich entmystifizieren,
also man könnte ja denken ah da hat jemand zufällig durchs teleskop guckt wie kevin das war aber nicht so es war ein brandneues teleskop zu der zeit hat viel geld gekostet,
musste ergebnisse liefern,
und damit hat man ja vorher schon systematisch die sonnenflecken erforscht und natürlich zu der damaligen zeiten hightech observatorium gehabt.
Ja justin time sozusagen.
Aber nicht zufällig dass auf der sonne der ausbruch stattfindet.
Ja das war der.
Das war das war aber ausbrüche hätte er so oder so beobachtet.
Die finden der mich permanent statt,
das heißt dann kam dann kam dieses spektrums kopie dazu auf einmal wusste man woraus die sonne eigentlich besteht also dieses sich bewusst werden das.
Die sonne.
Und die sterne eigentlich das gleiche sind ist das eine erkenntnis die früh kam oder die spät kam.
Ich würde sagen das kann man nicht voneinander trennen weil die sterne forschung ja auch unterwegs war und man hat eben aus den die spektrums kopie war eben der aufhänger,
daraus konnte man eben auf die chemischen zusammensetzung der sterne nicht nur der sonne schließen.
Also das ist der die bahnbrechende entwicklung gewesen und insofern.
Überraschung war es natürlich dass man jetzt wusste wie es die sonne zusammengesetzt was hast du auf video im kern fusion es ist immer eine frage wann ist es eine überraschung zu der zeit als es entdeckt wurde ja,
für uns natürlich heute nicht.
Ja für uns uns überrascht der überhaupt nichts mehr.
Ja das zeitgeist vielleicht aber gut wenn man dann weitergeht dann.
Wurden die sonnenuhr server tore hingebaut und vom boden aus und der nächste große schritt.
Es wurde wurden auch schon choreographen zur beobachtung der sonne unseren licht schwachen sonnenabend muskuläre wie wir sie von finsternis sonnenfinsternis sind total gerne den millionsten lichtschwerter ist die konnte man ja auch schon seit ewigen zeiten sehen.
Millionsten lichtschwert nur wenn der mond die sonne komplett verdeckt.
Und damals hat man finsternisse ja nicht nur wegen der sonne wäre systematisch untersucht und expeditionen geplant sondern auch um die einsteins gravitationsgesetz e oder relativitätstheorie,
beugung zu überprüfen benutzt.
Was ja dann letzten endes auch der durchbruch für seine theorie in der wissenschaft war.
Ja und dann hat es natürlich auch dazu geführt dass man eventuell sich vorstellen konnte dass von der sonne irgendwas ausgeht,
atmosphäre so bis ein paar sonnenreichen sondern tausend kilometer so etwa bis zwei drei millionen kilometer abstand vom sonnenrassel sieht man ja bei sonnenfinsternis die strahlend artigen weiß,
leuchtenden strukturen das ist übrigens gestreut das licht von elektronen sonnenlicht gestreut ist,
und die corona ändert sich auch das heißt wenn man selber jetzt die gelegenheit hätte die sonne wäre bei sonnenfinsternis ein paar mal zu beobachten dann sieht man sie sie doch unterschiedlich aus was dann auch wieder im zusammenhang mit dem magnetfeld,
legt oder damit zusammenhängt dass es auf der sonne magnetfelder gibt gut und parker hat dann eben,
eine theorie aufgestellt dass die sonne die mit ihrer enormen gravitation ihrer normen masse im vergleich zur erde die teilchen der äußeren atmosphäre ja gar nicht halten kann sondern sie müssen strömen nach seinen gleichungen.
Veröffentlichung achtundfünfzig eingereicht dreimal wieder zurückgekommen von den,
wir sahen gutachtern die an diese theorie nicht glaubt und von herrn parker stammt auch eben der name sonnenwind.
Und,
wir kommen ja später sicherlich noch zur neuen raumsonde die auch seinen namen trägt aber dann kam siebenundfünfzig kam er übrigens auch sputnik achtundfünfzig fand die gründung der nasa statt und dann kam eben diese enorme schritt dass man jetzt,
den raum zwischen sonne und erde mit satelliten erforschen konnte und eben den sonnenwind bestätigt hat gemessen hat jedes objekt,
im sonnensystem wird von diesem strom geladener teilchen primär wasserstoff helium und die elektronen.
Die von den atomen getrennt sind und das wissen wir eben nicht weshalb.
Hat das mit der heizung des sonnenwind mit der beschleunigung des sonnenwind es zu tun mit der frage wie entsteht da.
Der umströmt also alle objekte des sonnensystems planeten kometen und so weiter dehnt sich aus bis im abstand hundertfünfzig,
etwa hundertfünfzig astronomische einheiten das ist hundertfünfzig mal der abstand so eine erde.
Also etwa hundertfünfzig mal hundertfünfzig millionen kilometer im fast also dem.
Einen großen raum bereich weit über die den abstand der planeten hinaus,
danach kommt dann der interstellaren raus da kommt dann wind von von sternen und so weiter da hört also unsere helios fähre das heißt unser einflussbereich der sonne auf weil dann das gas zu dünn ist und,
ein von außen kommt in der interstellaren wind stärkeren einfluss hat.
Das im prinzip auch so ein bisschen die definition von wo das sonnensystem endet oder derzeit.
Für uns hört das ist es die helios wäre der einflussbereich der helios wäre und wir beschränken uns nicht auf den abstand der planeten und kometen.
Um es nochmal ein bisschen einzufangen also quasi mir so mit dem beginn der modernen wissenschaft also so mit,
einstein etcetera als dann einmal auch die die die physikalischen grundlagen gelegt waren für das wahre verständnis des,
universums ist dann eben auch die sonnenverschattung extrem intensiviert worden und nahm dann sozusagen nochmal neue beschleunigung auf mit den ganzen raumfahrt missionen,
schauen wir uns doch vielleicht bevor wir uns die modernen mission anschauen.
Einfach mal kurz an was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich für ein objekt was so meine sterne gibt es viele vor allem gibt es eine ganze menge viel größere richtig sehe ist unsere sonne,
einerseits stink normal und andererseits auch nicht besonders groß was uns durchaus zugute kommt,
was weiß man jetzt über den aufbau unserer sonne was was genau ist es.
Ja wir haben also erstmal ein kern den fünfzehn millionen grad temperatur herrschen dem.
Fünfzehn millionen grad.
Kern reaktionen stattfinden wobei wasserstoff zu helium verbrannt wird und die energie wird dann anschließend als strahlung freigesetzt läuft nach außen,
was sehr lange zeit braucht bis wir da ist die strahlung freigesetzt wird und wir haben dann so etwa ab,
zwei drittel vom kern nach außen bis zur oberfläche der sonnenscheibe gerechnet dort fängt dann an eine convention verwirbelung von materie tritt auf,
und es bilden sich sogenannte zellen das kann man sich wie eine strömung vorstellen von gas von flüssigkeiten,
und es ist eine strömung von elektrisch leitender materie,
dieser diese grenzschicht jetzt ungefähr so zweihunderttausend kilometer unter der sonnenoberfläche sich befindet ob der in einer bestimmten
abstand vom sonnenklar kern die konfektion auftritt bis zur oberfläche und da wird das magnetfeld der sonne generiert,
außen in der fotos wäre als sonnenflecken sichtbar wird man kann sich also die sonne ist ein dynamo dynamo prozess.
Ist wichtig dass sie rotiert rotiert nicht gleichmäßig am equator schneller als in höheren breiten.
Also man kann zum beispiel sonne untersuchen und stellt im weltraum fest okay dass der periode fünfundzwanzig tage siebenundzwanzig tage darauf können wir heute schließen aus welchem breiten auf der sonne gewisse dinge herkommen durch die verschiedene rotations zeit.
Hat man auch bei den sonnenflecken schon gesehen in früher dass die große sonnenflecken gruppen.
Deren breite hat sich geändert aber auch deren umlauf zeit war nahe des äquators schneller als in höheren beiden,
und.
Diese konvention die jetzt sozusagen in dem in den äußeren schichten unter der sonnenoberfläche auftreten.
Sind einmal mit dem dynamo prozess verbunden so dass man kann sich das anschaulich so vorstellen dass die materie.
Träumen besonnen der sonnenflecken zyklen vom äquator zu den polen hoch läuft und dann wieder,
runter zum äquator also eine umwälzung stattfindet und die sonne putzt sich eben alle elf jahre um einmal komplett.
Was putze ich um.
Die pole die magnetischen pole der sonne nord und südpol.
Alle elf jahre.
Elf jahre und einmal kompletter wechsel zweiundzwanzig jahre.
Und damit ist eben auch der sonnenflecken zyklus der elfjährige verknüpft und hat also mit diesem dynamik prozess im sonnenenergien zu tun,
sodass die magnetfelder die sonnenflecken ein sichtbare erscheinung der aufsteigenden materie der magnetischen materie sind.
Sonnenflecken sind kühler.
Also die sonne ist ein brodeln der gast bei in dem magnetisch des plasma zur oberfläche kommt sich abkühlt wieder da unten fällt und da gibt's dann eben verschiedene skalen kleines geilen überall ist es magnetisch sonnenflecken.
Dann haben wir ja den elfjährigen sonnenflecken zyklus.
Wir sind jetzt im minimum dann haben wir das nächste maximum etwa zwotausend dreiundzwanzig da haben wir dann besonders viele solcher flecken.
Nochmal kurz gut zu verstehen weil es ist ein bisschen viel auf einmal nochmal also wir haben den den kern da findet im wesentlichen diese fusion statt so das macht zwei drittel ungefähr der von uns wahrgenommenen größe der sonne aus,
das ist sozusagen so ein.
Permanenter feuerball der eben wirklich unheimlich viel energie erzeugt das ist sozusagen diese diese unglaubliche strahlungshitze.
Darüber ist dann was durch diese strahlung entstanden.
Also was muss man sich sozusagen als nächste schicht dieser sonnen zwiebel vorstellen.
Da haben wir dann die konvention tone.
Und was heißt das genau konvention was das ist dieses blubbern dieses diese blasenbildung sozusagen von diesem heißen plasberg.
Das kann man sich so vorstellen das kann man sich so vorstellen dass dort eine strömung aus dem sondern inneren ab diesen höhen entsteht die zur oberfläche drängt sich abkühlt und wieder absackt.
Das heißt da blubbert's sozusagen die ganze die kochende oberfläche das was man eigentlich sozusagen auch als oberfläche jetzt wahrnehmen würde.
Es gab doch vor ein paar tagen so eine wunderbare veröffentlichung von einem teleskop in hawaii.
Das neueste teleskop.
Die von der erde aus quasi diese oberfläche beobachtet und dann eben auch mal visualisiert haben das ist ein tatsächliches richtiges foto oder ist das eine berechnete grafik gewesen.
Nein es gibt tatsächlich fotos oder fotos die aneinander gereiht zu filmen werden die die dynamik zeigen.
Und das sei ja aus wie so ein ich weiß nicht wie so ein.
Einzelne maiskolben artige strukturen würde ich sagen oder wie seifenblasen eigentlich aneinander gereiht,
ich glaube jedes ding irgendwie so von der größe von texas und so muss man sich sozusagen diese diese heiße oberfläche vorstellen.
Sprechen wir auch von der gratulation super gratulation diesen kleinen poren auf der sonne so wie ein.
Warmen stock vermieden sieht das aus ganz vereinfacht.
Und das hat eben mit dieser konfektion aus dem inneren zu schulen dass ein muster eine abbildung.
Wobei es nicht die einzige abbildung ist also wenn man jetzt über das sonnenenergie spricht dann ist die erforschung des sonnenenergien durch die entwicklung der helios eismond logie vorangetrieben werden da werden wir sicherlich später,
im zusammenhang mit der mission dazu kommen aber es wichtig jetzt schon vom verständnis her dass die sonne eben ein schwingender gast ball ist,
schallwellen erzeugt werden die sich im inneren ausbreiten.
Richtung laufen dann dort bei der großen dichter am kern reflektiert werden wieder nach außen sodass die sonne ein schwingungs muster erzeugt und diese schwingung muster wird,
angeregt wird durch temperatur des gases durch die magnetfelder,
die rotation der sonne beeinflusst und wenn man diese schwingungsebene muster in der wissenschaft analysieren kann kann man darauf rückschlüsse ziehen auf den körper selbst.
Was folgt jetzt auf diese,
diese oberfläche ein bisschen schwierig bei so etwas strahlenden blubbernde sich permanent gleichzeitig ausdehnen und in sich zusammenfallen den körper von von von irgendwie so definierten orten zu sprechen aber das ist ja sozusagen,
diese diese,
das war jetzt nochmal der begriff konfektionsmaßen blasen diese diese blubber oberfläche das ist sozusagen diese eigentliche fotos fähre also der.
Sichtbare teil darüber entwickelt sich dann diese corona also das was,
quasi nochmal über diese eigentliche begrenzung mit meiner von so richtigen ende kann man wahrscheinlich an der stelle gar nicht so richtig sprechen was ich darüber bildet wo dann permanent diese plasma explosion von dieser sonne ausgehen,
richtig.
Das stimmt ja also aus der fotos faire grund legend ist dass man eine oberfläche hat der sonne eben die fotos wäre die überall magnetisch wert ist überall in form kleinerer größerer bip ole,
plus gesamtfeld der sonne das,
manchmal im einfachen fall wie das der erde eines hufeisen magneten ganz anschaulich gesprochen entspricht und sich eben in diesem innerhalb dieser elf jahre umgepolt und überall gibt's aber kleine magnetfelder auf der,
die größeren die wir sehen können sind die sonnenflecken.
Und bei den sonnenflecken ist es so dass wir eben nur die gebiete sehen mit der stärksten magnetfeld konzentration aber es gehören immer ein positiver pool und ein negativer oder ein nord und ein südpol zusammen.
Und wenn man sonnenflecken beobachter da sieht man immer nur ein teil des magnetfeldes beim heutigen aufnahmen kann man das magnetfeld der sonne beobachten.
Und es als gesamtes see also ein problem von den sonnenflecken ist ich sehe.
Nur gebiete die eine bestimmte stärke haben intensität auf der sonnenoberfläche nicht aber das gesamte magnet und,
dann ist es so dass das der ursprung ist von magnetischen strukturen an denen sich geladenen teilchen,
befinden gebunden an die magnetfelder und das reicht dann raus sozusagen über die sonnenoberfläche in den weltraum hinaus.
Die dichte nimmt enorm schnell ab dehnt sich also das magnetfeld die die schleifen enorm aus in ganz geringen abstand in,
hunderttausend kilometer über der sonnenoberfläche haben also diese schleifen die dann aber auch millionen kilometer weit nach außen ragen können je nachdem wie die expansion stattfindet je nachdem wie das magnetfeld.
An der oberfläche und kurz unter der oberfläche strukturiert ist und das macht dann die sonnenabend wäre und da gibt es eben auch die emissionen linien von in diesem hochdosierten eisen,
im ultraviolette im röntgen licht das ist also licht was für vom erdboden aus gar nicht beobachten konnten vor dem beginn des weltraum zeitalters die ersten messungen hat man in usa gemacht.
Der röntgens emission der sonne und der ultraviolett emission das war mit,
raketen research laboratory washington d c zwar eins vor zwei raketen leider und.
Mit denen hat man direktoren geflogen und da hat man dann man muss in einer bestimmten höhe messungen machen weil die erdatmosphäre uns zum glück abschirmen vor dieser harten strahlung,
wir sprechen immer vom röntgen und extrem ultraviolettes weil das ultraviolettes licht indem die atmosphäre der sonne strahlt nah am röntgen bereich ist,
wellenlängen so zweieinhalb strömen oder zwanzig meter meter wir haben ja sichtbares das befindet sich um fünfhundert kilometer rum kann man sehen wie kurzfristig das ist und dann hat man festgestellt a.
Das wussten wir ja noch gar nicht da strahlt die sonne also doch im im röntgen licht.
Und diese röntgenstrahlung die wir auch als licht plätze kennen hängt wieder mit dem magnetfeld zusammen,
überlagert sich dem normalen spektrum der sonne als schwarzer strahler die man so kennt primär im sichtbaren kennen wir aber diese emissionen röntgen und uv-licht dringt wird von der erdatmosphäre absorbiert.
Das heißt erst mit dem wiederum mit dem sprung sowie beim sonnenwind auch da konnte ich also die erde verlassen,
die erdatmosphäre dann das magnetfeld befinde mich im raum zwischen sonne und der erde kann direkt die teilchen messen kann feststellen oder raum ist nicht leer da gibt's den sonnenwind genauso hat man feststellen können mit hilfe,
das überwinden sozusagen der erdatmosphäre dann auch mit raum sondern,
oh die sonne strahlt hier im röntgen und ultraviolettes licht und nur so kann ich die äußere sonnenabend wäre beobachten.
Dazu gehört natürlich auch noch die tatsache dass man kameras fliegen kann,
die die streuung der erdatmosphäre verhindern und somit auch künstliche sonnenfinsternis oder die sonne immer beobachten war machen wir also auch wieder ein ganz fundamentaler sprung.
Die durch die weltraumforschung der durch die weltraumforschung ermöglicht wurde.
Also wenn man jetzt die quasi die struktur der sonne mal grob kartografiert haben kann man ja mal zu den missionen die nun tatsächlich geflogen wurden vielleicht mal weitergehen man muss auch dazu sagen sie waren bei einer ganzen reihe,
wenn ich,
alles so in den letzten zwanzig jahren was so an so ein bisschen geflogen ist in irgendeiner form beteiligt richtig oder also zumindestens ihre homepage mit nahezu allen,
projekt baches gepflastert die ich so ausmachen konnte,
es wurde ja eben schon erwähnt siebziger jahre ging's im prinzip eigentlich erst so richtig los mit diesen helios mission das war ja schon eine deutsch-amerikanische kooperation aber weil sie wahrscheinlich noch nicht dabei oder.
Doch ich habe meine promotion ja an den helios daten.
Ah ja stimmt das haben sie ja schon erwähnt ja ok.
Erarbeitet das war ja einfach eine ideale sache um zu wissen was macht der sonnenwind.
Ja ok alles klar das heißt damit fängt's im prinzip an also es waren zwei sondern und sechsundsiebzig gestartet das war wahrscheinlich noch relativ einfache systeme.
Ja unterscheiden sich nicht großartig von dem institut messungen des sonnenwind es heute das was bei julius der fall war war es waren keine kameras zu der damaligen zeit die auf die sonne gerichtet waren erstmal nicht an bord und dann auch
konnte man nur auf daten kataloge von observatorium zurückgreifen und,
zur zeit als ich also an helios gearbeitet habe am max-planck-institut.
Da hat ich eben das glück dass mein betreuer ein doktor vater an der helios an der sohn mission aktiv mitgearbeitet hat und julia.
Wurde gestartet also ich habe einundneunzig mit neunzig mit der promotion angefangen das war gerade der staat der julis raumsonde.
Und das war also die erste mission die den sonnenwind außerhalb der erdumlaufbahn vermessen hat.
Und das hat auch dazu geführt also beide beide eine reihe von faktoren also einmal die.
Mitzuverfolgen wie eine neue sonnen mission nämlich so geplant wird zum anderen ist.
Joko gestartet worden und hat die ersten fantastischen bilder der.
Äußeren der röntgens atmosphäre der sonne geliefert ist auf jedem jedem lehrbuch drauf gewesen hast du für signal zu spektakulär,
und dann julia und.
Ich hatte dann auch das große vergnügen dass ich bei der auswahl für die elisa angenommen wurde und eben nach meiner promotion,
fällt mir gerade ein war sicherlich auch wichtig dass,
in dem moment indem ich jetzt neunzehnhundertdreiundneunzig die promotion beendet habe war ich vier wochen später schon mit meinen ergebnissen dabei eine weltraummission zu planen zum weltraum wetter,
schon sowas wie ein vorläufer von stereo und konnte dann auch gleich einsteigen in die ins nasa team wo die stereo mission entwickelt wurde das passiert also schon auf den kenntnissen die man dann gesammelt hat sonne und erde welcher sonnenwind ist es und was muss man untersuchen
und ich hatte dann aber eben bei der esa zwei jahre die aufgabe des instrument,
zu betreuen und die daten zu analysieren während der zeit des umzugs der sonnenpause und dadurch haben wir also eine mission gehabt auch der auch keine kameras drauf waren aus bestimmten gründen,
ist das irgendwann mal hinfällig geworden was man ursprünglich geplant hat auch technologisch,
das kann man sich so vorstellen wenn man jetzt die erde kartieren will fliegt mit dem satelliten immer um equator geht das einfach nicht man muss also doch in einen neuen bereich kommen und julis,
aus der antike entdeckung der unbekannten gebiete des mittelmeeres julis.
Flug quasi über die sonnenpause erstmalige vermessung des ganzen raumes war da ein weiterer schritt.
Und hat uns erkenntnisse gebracht wie der sonnenwind,
insgesamt strukturiert ist welche wellen auftreten welche phänomene die messung haben aber.
Im abstand der erde stattgefunden bis einigen gastronomischen einheiten.
Man ist dann in um die sonne geflogen aber hat sozusagen nicht den abstand verändert und.
Im wesentlichen alles so auf der erdumlaufbahn beschäftigt hat.
Richtig genau genau und danach war mein glück wieder so hoch wurde erfolgreich gestartet,
und ich war dann in der lage diese wissenschaftler stelle eine zu bekommen die es gab in deutschland,
und zwar für die analyse von energiereichen teilchen die von der sonne kommen gemessen mit einem instrument an bord von so.
Jetzt haben wir mal im prinzip schon zwanzig jahre mission angesprochen also helios war mitte der siebziger jahre julis die zweite mission diese erwähnten war anfang der neunziger jahre so dann mitte der neunziger jahre
sehe ich das richtig dass das jetzt nahezu alles immer esa und nasa also deutsch-amerikanische kooperation waren.
Also helios war eine rein deutsch-amerikanische mission,
dann haben wir ja julia julia es war in der tat ein esel nasa mission und zwar der lit kommt von der esa rakete wird von der nasa gestellt dann haben wir so da war das auch der fall.
Rakete nasa würde lied esa und.
Stereo ist zum beispiel eine rhein amerikanische mission also nicht immer so.
Okay aber da ist auf jeden fall eine achse schon über lange zeit entstanden.
Ja der achse mit positiven und negativen aspekten denn man wollte ja ursprünglich bei zwei sonnenbaum eine für den norden und eine für den südpol der sonne und aus kostengründen hat die nasa gesagt nein machen wir nicht,
aber da steckt ja auch viel mehr dahinter und da gibt's natürlich auch einen gewissen konkurrenzkampf wer kriegt die größte aufmerksamkeit und,
aber entscheidend ist zu erwähnen dass so eine fantastische mission ist und zwar aus den gründen weil.
Man satelliten fliegen hat der übrigens nach über zwanzig jahren immer noch funktioniert und die sonne im.
Allen wellenlängen bereichen beobachten kann und zwar simultan.
Und in einem punkt wo es kein tag und nacht gibt guckt immer auf die sonne vierundzwanzig stunden dreihundertfünfundsechzig tage im jahr.
Was ganz fundamental zu wissen ist für die untersuchung der schwingungen der sonne über die wir ja schon besprochen haben,
wenn man auf der erde ist hat schlecht wetter oder kann nur ein teil des tages beobachten kann man auch nur ein teil der schwingung aufzeichnen zeitlich hat immer wieder lücken drin und das war einer der.
Schlüssel speckte für die mission die helios eismond die untersuchung der sonneninsel durch wellen ausbreitung.
Hinzu kommen die instrumente die jetzt.
Früher haben wir ja immer das problem gehabt wenn der seine teleskop hat beobachtet das andere nicht tag und nacht und schlecht wetter und dann muss man um gewisse dinge zu verstehen die ja auf der sonne ausgelöst werden,
auf ihrer oberfläche und dann effekte haben in der darüberliegenden korona.
Dann simultan beobachtung haben muss und da hatten wir viele teleskope drauf.
Die die sichtbare sonnenscheibe das magnetfeld gleichzeitig aufgenommen haben.
Den schwingungen der sonne mit den strukturen der corona und zwar im ultraviolettes.
Und im sichtbaren bereich bis hin zu dem sonnenwind der dann bei so angekommen.
Das war also ein einzigartiges sonnenauf und dann während der,
arbeit an so mit vielen neuen erkenntnissen zum sonnen inneren,
zur konfektionsmaßen zone zur zum sonnenflecken zyklus zu corolla zu ihren zu ihren konnte mit so also auch das erste mal bis,
zum abstand von zwanzig kilo millionen kilometer die korona nach außen verfolgen hat auch kometen tausende von kometen mittlerweile beobachtet die man sonst nicht sehen kann weil die sonne zu hell ist und diese,
gleichzeitig gleichzeitig daten in verschiedenen bereichen der sonne und ihre atmosphäre zur verfügung zu haben hat zu einem enormen.
Erkenntnisgewinn geführt also früher haben wir immer gedacht so ein ausbruch auf der sonne,
paar sonnenreichen abstand von der sonne riesig groß da muss also die gesamte atmosphäre quasi explodieren ist aber nicht so sondern es ist einfach so dass aus gebieten wie sonnenflecken magnetfeld strukturen sich innerhalb von,
minuten auf riesiges geilen.
Ausbreiten expandieren können sodass man sich vorstellen kann anschaulich dass die erde wie so 'ne stecknadel durch so ein sonnenstrom fegt die größenordnung und zeitgleich haben wir dann.
Bei der analyse der so daten festgestellt.
Uns fehlt ja was was uns fehlte war wir gucken zur sonne und die sonne wäre deren auswirkungen ist transparent wir gucken durch.
Dann fehlt uns also so ein komischer blick.
Die abbildung des sonne erde systems das verfolgen von dingen die auf der sonne ausgelöst worden sonnenwind sonnenstürme bis hin zur erde und das hat dann ja auch wurde im rahmen der stereo mission geplant.
Finde ich sehr froh dass ich daran beteiligt war in dem da sein team und das wäre dann diese mission dann auch umgesetzt haben also jede dieser mission hat eine kernziele setzung hab die anlass war julius unter der sonnenwind.
Quasi dreidimensional in der helios fähre außerhalb der erdumlaufbahn so hohe als großes observatorium zeitgleich messungen stereo das erste mal einen blick mit kameras von außen die auch,
neuerdings oder neuartig den gesamten beobachtungsgabe reich zwischen sonne und erde erfassen.
Weil das muss man an der stelle auch nochmal erwähnen es sich hier um eine doppel mission gehandelt hat das heißt nicht nur ein zettel die das losgeflogen sondern zwei die überhaupt finde ich an diesem ganzen zusammenhang sehr interessant wo diese ganzen,
mission sich so platziert haben also julis es hat so einen riesigen radius drumrum gemacht weil man wollte sozusagen die kompletten auswirkungen der sonne auch,
sehr viel weiter als die erde entfernten bereich messen können so wo waren glaube ich die erste mission die diesen lange punkt eins genutzt hat also quasi den
ort zwischen sonne und erde wo sich die anziehungskraft e soweit neutralisieren dass man das quasi mit der erde einfach immer mitfliegen kann aber sozusagen immer die erde im rücken die sonne im blick hat
und diese stereo mission wenn es richtig verstanden habe lief zwar auf der laufbahn mit,
die beiden aber in unterschiedlichen geschwindigkeiten sodass sie immer aus unterschiedlichen perspektiven auf die sonne geschaut haben und die sich aber auch,
am laufenden meter verändert hat also der abstand zwischen diesen beiden satelliten als ich am laufenden meter verändert ist das richtig.
Und zwar funktioniert das so dass man dass wir in diesem team konzept erarbeitet haben und ursprünglich war das mal so wir wollten einfach nur seitlich auf sonne und erde gucken.
Um dreidimensionales bild zu erzeugen das war ja sagen wir mal das primärziel oder.
Ja das sieht also einfach dreidimensional ist noch ein bisschen komplexer da braucht man dann noch mehr sondern für die wirkliche dreidimensionalität aber einfach.
Aber mehr als nur eine person.
Und dann eben auch das erste mal von außen auf sonne und erde gleichzeitig zu gucken,
die kameras die wir sind ja wirklich so technologisch entwickelt dass dieses licht was ja bei der sonneneinfluss fähre bei der sonnenfinsternis millionen licht schwächer ist davon ist ja weiter weg schon fast gar nichts mehr da und das können wir tatsächlich heutzutage filmen,
sogar sichtbar machen was über die erde an an sonnenstürmen drüber läuft aber zurück zum start das war also eine mission mit zwei satelliten genau aus,
grund der zielsetzung weil man wollte die struktur in der tat von sonnenstürmen analysieren von kommunalen masse auswerfen.
Und das waren ja wie wir vorher in den jahren rausgefunden haben die sonne ereignisse die bei uns auf der erde die gravierenden stürmer auslosen die hat magnetisch damit plus ihrer folgeerscheinungen des weltraum wetters und,
deren dreidimensionalität konnten wir mit stereo erstmals erfassen und zwar funktioniert das so ein staat die beiden satelliten.
Fliegen beim mond vorbei die eine der.
Zusammen gestartet wurde.
Deswegen sind sie auch nicht,
absolut baugleich weil ja die beiden satelliten aufeinander gestapelt wurden im kopf der rakete das bedeutet dass man dazu schon mal die den aufsatz ring verstärken muss des unteren satelliten.
Dann kriegen sie in zwei verschiedene richtungen das heißt die antennen setzen an zwei verschiedenen stellen.
Sie sind nahezu identisch gleichen instrumenten und der eine satellit der ist eben etwas dichter als die erdumlaufbahn an der sonne.
Statt ein astronomischen einheit sind es nur null komma neun sechs im mittel und nach den kryptischen gesetzen bewegt sich im körper schneller einmal um die sonne,
einmal im jahr brauchen wir dreihundertfünfundsechzig tage.
Stereo braucht nur dreihundertvierzig ungefähr stereo ist etwas weiter weg eins komma null vier.
Satellit braucht dreihundertachtzig tage das heißt nach einem jahr einmal um die sonne rum.
Dann ist der eine satellit noch nicht ganz um die sonne rum und der andere schon etwas,
mehr etwas weiter als die erdumlaufbahn sodass pro jahr dieser winkel zweiundzwanzig grad zwischen satellit und so eine erde richtung beträgt,
und damit driften die dann innerhalb der jahre auseinander und wir können je nach missions zeitraum verschiedene beobachtungen machen also am anfang der mission konnten wir tatsächlich aktive gebiete auf der sonne,
dreidimensional untersuchen unter dem kleinen winkel drauf geguckt haben nachher standen irgendwann die satelliten.
Einander gegenüber und haben also die eine hälfte der sonne gesehen und die andere hälfte.
Aber man konnte das erste mal die sonne komplett in dreihundertsechzig grad quasi.
Das war das war tatsächlich so zweitausendelf haben wir einen zeitpunkt erwischt wo wir das erste mal von die sonne rundum dreihundertsechzig grad aufnahmen,
hinzu kam dann eben auch noch zweitausendacht der stadt von so nochmal zum vergleich also wir haben den start von so gehabt neunzehnhundertfünfundneunzig und,
gott sei dank guter start.
Hat meine stelle ermöglicht die forschungsstelle und dann ebenso staat der stereo mission,
die wir angefangen haben vierundneunzig zu planen statt zwotausendsechs zwölf jahre das sind so etwa die zeit skalen der missions entwicklung.
Und stereo bayern erst zehn jahre später nach so hoch.
Das war also dann der der sprung so eine erde räumlich und zweitausendacht in der satellit,
also im vergleich zu so der sitzt nicht im lager der fliegt um die erde rum im orbit.
Also steht für solar.
Observatory und zielsetzung zielsetzung sind hochaufgelösten beobachtung der sonne.
Die wir mit so nicht bekommen und dazu ist es um die daten alle runterzufahren funken sich vorstellen wir kriegen eine datenmenge von einer dvd pro minute runter.
Das ist riesig über und über die jahre haben wir also die sonne da haben wir's geilen gesehen auf den vorgänge ablaufen ja das ist dann schon.
Wichtig weil man dann die theorien auch wieder anpassen muss durch die neuen beobachtungen.
Nochmal kurz kontext zu kriegen also helios und es ist so auch stereo waren eigentlich,
sind der sonne nicht wirklich sehr viel näher gekommen nur etwas näher so ging so ein bisschen zwischen erde und sonne aber halt im wesentlichen immer noch im kontext der erde damit man da auch irgendwie gut kommunizieren konnte,
sehe ich das richtig dass jetzt die mission ab zwanzig zehn also ist so leider observatory das erste ist was der sonne auch wirklich nahe gerückt ist.
Am wenigsten weil solange deine milch die hochaufgelösten daten machen sollte und macht zu erde zurück punkt und deswegen am dichtesten bei der erde ist,
also die also alle stereo sind alles erdbeeren nahe,
sonnen gewesen oder satellitenfilm mehr,
helios ist die einzige mission bis vor kurzem gewesen die sich bis auf merkur nähe sozusagen der sonne genähert hat.
Aber näher ran ist halt schwierig weil es heiß.
Ja man hat ja aber gesagt okay wir fliegen wir zur sonne das war schon neunzehnhundertachtundfünfzig der fall da kam schon die ersten ideen,
wir brauchen eine mission und zwar deswegen als herr parker den ich kenne der.
Der noch lebt obwohl er schon lange dabei.
Ja da gibt's ja dieses schöne geschichte dass ich promoviert habe bei max blank und,
mein vater sonnenwind konferenz in goslar organisiert hat und da ich also mehr da ferien arbeiten musste ein bisschen geld zu verdienen bin ich gefahren,
für firmen und dann durfte ich also auch die gäste abholen von hannover flughafen und einer der gäste war parker.
Und da habe ich gedacht na ja wenn du jetzt das den wagen in gaben setzt ist die karriere beendet ja noch gar nicht angefangen hatte
und das schöne ist dass ich dann die ergebnisse der provokation die auch eine wesentliche rolle spielten für die entwicklung von stereo von der stereo mission und von anderen dingen,
zur erforschung des windes achtundneunzig getroffen habe und da hat jemand wir haben einen waren also zu dritt
zwei theoretiker weitere theoretische physiker und dann habe ich halt parka mir eine widmung geschrieben dass ich ja als fahrer damals den sprung gemacht hatte mit der entdeckung des neuen twists im sonnenwind.
Und damals wusste ich aber nicht dass die mission,
zola probt die wir geplant haben später geplant haben weil achtundneunzig es gab viele teams und technisch noch nicht möglich mal zur sonne hinzufliegen das erste mal die atmosphäre eine stern zu besuchen dass die mission dann natürlich nachher in park pop um benannt wird,
das freut mich dann immer auch in meinen vorträgen erzähle ich es natürlich super gerne aber es war einfach nicht geplant und ja wir haben dann ja während der,
analyse der oder während der arbeit an stereo natürlich zwei zwei weiteren missionen geplant und da haben wir eben die zielsetzung gehabt jetzt wollen wir eigentlich nicht dran.
Und das sind die beiden missionen die gerade aktuell fliegen also mit der probe.
Da haben wir zweitausenddrei angefangen die nasa gesagt hat.
Jetzt sind wir mit einem hitzeschild weitergekommen jetzt können wir es schaffen und wir machen doch nochmal ein neues team,
team nummer vielleicht zwölf oder so und dann habe ich mich beworben habe die einladung ins nasa team bekommen und dann haben wir eine mission geplant wo wir dachten oh das machen wir jetzt alles so wie mit violet hat sich ja bewährt,
zum jupiter schwung holen,
und dann auf drei sonnenreichen ran über die oberfläche und da waren wir dann schon bei eins komma zwei fünf milliarden dollar in einem kostenrahmen aktive batterie,
flugzeit nach außen vier jahre zum jupiter so grob da natürlich schwung geht ein bisschen schneller zu sonne,
dann zehn stunden messezeit und zack wieder zurück zum jupiter und dann hat die nasa gesagt nee nee nee erstens zu teuer zweitens die batterie gefällt uns nicht und vielleicht könnt ihr ja nochmal euch ransetzen und die mission optimieren,
dem war das übrigens kann ich mich gut erinnern der ja eine zeit lang direktor der wissenschafts- direktor unseres bereiches bei der nasa wo und dann anschließend der prinzipiell dafür pluto.
Aber es hat gesagt so setzt euch jetzt nochmal hin siebenhundertfünfzigtausend siebenhundertfünfzig millionen dollar und,
lasst euch mal was einfallen und dann haben wir erstmal angefangen wissenschaftlich zu überlegen wie dicht müssen wir überhaupt an die sonne ran um die zielsetzung.
Zu erfüllen die die uns zum erkenntnis führen weil eine der fragen war ja wie wird die corona erzeugt überhaupt wie entsteht der sonnenwind.
Gerade warum warum gibt's eigentlich eisen vierzehn dort es gibt zwar theorien aber es gibt viele theorien und,
nur vor ort das kann man also durch die bilder nicht durch die spektrums kopie wieder konnte man das nicht in drehsesseln deswegen wollen wir da hin wollten da hin und da haben wir gesagt ja das können wir auch klären,
wenn wir statt auf drei bis auf neun sonnenreiche sowas kommen neunzehn sonnenreichen weil die berechnung sagen da,
über den bereich gibt es diese mechanismen noch die zum sonnenwind führen die die krone erzeugen und dann konnte man das hitzeschild ein bisschen,
reduzieren und man konnte es sind dann eben jetzt nur nur noch quasi in anführungszeichen tausendfünfhundert grad aber nicht mehr noch höhere temperaturen,
und wir kommen dorthin durch vielfache vorbeiflüge an der venus zum abbremsen.
Das heißt man muss sich so weit raus das geht alles ein bisschen schneller und dadurch wird's billiger.
Es wird.
Also billig ist nicht der richtige weg wir haben damals der also der erste das erste erste konzept entwurf der ingenieure hier ist ihr macht ihr zoller pro pleite.
Aber das ist ein ganz falscher irreführender begriff also ich denke dadurch dass wir die mission um konzipiert haben ist einfach viel besser geworden und zwar deswegen wir haben nicht mehr diese langen durchstrecken zum jupiter,
jupiter ist schädlich für die von der strahlung her von den teilchen her für die messung für die konzeption der instrumente wir brauchen die radioaktive batterie nicht mehr wir haben was wir brauchen war.
Ein missions konzept mit einer reihe serie von vorbeiflüge an der venus.
Und dann den gravity assists wir haben können wir gleich noch drüber sprechen wie wie es mit der mission läuft und so weiter wir brauchen vor allem eine rakete,
eine starke und das haben wir dann mit der delta heavy gehabt ein gehabt,
stärkste rakete die es zurzeit gibt bis auf die die bei space-x jetzt entwickelt werden und das ermöglicht es uns im august zweitausendachtzehn,
zu starten venus flug zu machen,
august statt oktober vom beifügung an der venus und nach achtzig tage nach dem start war mir der sonne so nah wie nie zuvor nämlich bei,
etwa achtundzwanzig millionen kilometer viel dichter als vorher.
Ja ok ich finde ich finde diese phase jetzt gerade aus mehreren aspekten ganz interessant also einerseits weil man sich ja dann sozusagen immer diese,
also man muss ja quasi immer alles im kopf haben man muss die eigenen
wissenschaftlichen ziele im kopf haben man muss so ein budget irgendwie im kopf haben oder zumindest kommt es bei den berechnungen dann irgendwo so indirekter,
auch mal wieder bei raus und dann weiß man wiederum muss im prinzip nochmal von vorne anfangen aber vor allem muss man ja hier auch das know-how von sehr vielen leuten insbesondere aus der mission analyse bekommen weil es ist ja nicht so dass man,
dass man das so weiß ah ja okay dann lass mal nur so nah ran fliegen nur neun nee was was war da war der abstand die sie erreichen wollen.
Moin sonnenbrand.
Neun sonnenrassel nicht augen natürlich so daraus leitet sich nicht automatisch eine anflug,
richtung und ein ein ablauf von gravity ab sondern das ist sind ja selber dann nochmal aufwendige komplexe berechnungen die missions analytiker durchführen muss,
das kostet ja auch zeit sowohl solche dinge mal wieder durchzuführen oder ist das gar nicht mehr so aufwendig,
gibt es nur noch drei daten in seinem laptop ein oder ein wasser wir fliegen muss.
Nein nein also einmal werden ja auch solche teams zusammengesetzt aus experten oder.
Davon wird man ausgeben.
Wissenschaftlern die entsprechend kenntnis haben und dann diese mission konzipieren also wir haben fünfzehn personen im team grob gehabt und wir wurden unterstützt von ingenieuren und so weiter.
Aber was ist denn das also für ein rundlauf wenn man sagt okay jetzt jetzt fliegen wir aber anders bis man wirklich bei dieser diesem detaillierten plan ist mit diesen zwei mal einer venus vorbei et cetera und wir brauchen so ein so eine starke rakete ist das macht man das so an einem nachmittag oder.
Ja wir haben pro jahr eine anzahl von team-meetings die offiziell sind die hießen meetings des nasal heinz technology definition team und die finden da sitzen wir dann drei tage von acht bis acht zusammen.
Und dann wird das alles aufgeschrieben und diskutiert.
Für ziele hat.
Ja was man für ziele hat und wie die technologie ist eine zeitlang schmeißt man alle kameras runter.
Zu technisch zu kompliziert wird wir haben mal ein konzept gehabt indem wir gesagt haben okay dann klappen wir.
Ausleger dann benutzen wir ausleger aber diese ausleger die müssen ja durch das hitzeschild geschützt werden und das treten eben über eine gewisse strecke,
über die materialien thermische gradient auf und all diese dinge kamera weggelassen komplexität verringert genau die instrumente definiert die,
die fragestellung erfüllen dazu müssen natürlich die fragestellung ausgearbeitet werden die da sind wie wird entsteht der sonnenwind wie entsteht die korona.
Elementare wir werden energiereiche teilchen da der sonne erzeugt die bei uns zu strahlen belastung von astronauten flugzeug.
Personal führen und das heißt das thema weltraum wetter.
Aber von diesem zeitpunkt aus wo man weiß okay wenn wir müssen jetzt eine kleinere lösung eine andere lösung in anderen ansatz finden bis zu,
jetzt haben wir auch einen vorschlag der ist mal durchgerechnet worden wir wollen genauso und so fliegen in der und der ausstattung,
wie lange dauert das ist das eine sache von tagen wochen monaten jahren.
Wir haben bei stereo für die ausarbeitung zwei bis drei jahre gebraucht wir haben den beim bei der ersten version für die zwei jahre gebraucht und dann nochmal zwei jahre drangehängt.
Also für die kleinere variante sozusagen musste man nochmal zwei jahre lang planen bis man überhaupt ein plan hat den man vorlegen kann der dann erstmal genehmigt werden.
Ja das ist dann ein dokument so sogenannter science definition team report der die angabe der rakete der instrumente der wissenschaftlichen zielsetzung,
und der gewissen machbarkeit beinhaltet und der wird dann von der nasa begutachtet und wenn die dann sagt unsere gutachter sagen auch das hat er gemacht,
dann wird diese mission ins programm aufgenommen und das ist zweitausendacht neun erfolgt und dann kommt als nächster schritt die ausschreibung.
Baut das ding.
Wer baut die kameras wer baut den satelliten welche rakete nehmen wir.
Wobei die rakete ja in gewisser hinsicht auch gesetzt war weil man ja schon davon ausging dass die sehr sehr sehr stark sein muss das ist ja teil der mission berechnung und so viele.
Ja da gibt's aber unheimlich spannende geschichten zu erzählen also die,
also da ich ja den deutschen beitrag leite und die mission mit geplant habe kann ich natürlich wenn ich natürlich auch von den deutschen budget abhängig und man muss sich überlegen wo mache ich bei der mission mit wenn man bei der planung dabei ist mal noch nicht automatisch derjenige der beim instrument dabei.
Und wir hatten ja nun stereo laufen und dann habe ich verschiedene anfragen gehabt und da habe ich mir überlegt ja ich möchte auch ganz gerne wieder bei der kamera für den sonnenwind dabei sein was ja auch wieder verknüpft ist mit,
göttingen raus und jetzt fliegen wir ja zu den ursprüngen von,
der sonnenwind ist von dem gas gesprochen hat deswegen heißt es habe ich mir dann eine beteiligung überlegt an dieser kamera die ich abgekürzt habe mit graffiti german pop.
Und dass es fehlt weil diese kamera,
den sonnenwind beobachten soll und wenn man jetzt von der erde vielleicht schon mal was von gehört hat von den am sonnenlicht des an staubteilchen gestreut ist das wollen wir grade weghaben,
das nennen die wissenschaftler f corona und sonst hätte es nämlich tfd raus und das klappte dann mit der abkürzung ja wieder nicht also das ist ein super name das ist die deutsche beteiligung an der kamera und,
da musste ich auch sehr viel überzeugungsarbeit leisten weil der howard mein kollege mit dem ich schon stereo gemacht hab,
die planeten kameras und die choreographen dazu beiträge da wollte man ursprünglich keine kamera drauf fliegen haben.
Warum muss man denn kurz mal zwischen zu gehen.
Wo kommt denn immer dieser zwang her dass diese komischen abkürzungen auch immer noch irgendwas richtiges heißen weil wenn man das ding einfach gas nennen will warum nennt man es da nicht einfach gas und wenn jemand fragt was es heißt sagt man ja sonnenwind kamera.
Ja weil die die wir leben in der welt von akronym und die akronym e sollen auch in bestimmten sinn haben und das ziel das brauche ich für corona.
Gebe ich ein anderes beispiel die mechanismen die,
vor dem uv teleskop von den kameras vor dem image und den chronograph befinden die sind in meinem team als ich bei max blank war entwickelt worden und das sind verschlüsse,
und da haben wir die kameras die ganze sweet der kameras säcke genannt,
und zwar nach dem italienischen astronomen der erste bilder der korona photometrische gemacht hat achtzehnhundert auch sechzig rum und dann haben wir gesagt sexy steht für sunny connection coronel in helios investigation,
jetzt wird's noch lustiger jetzt stehe ich da mit meinem projekt und habe ja quasi die türen oder die mechanismen die die.
Die filter zum beispiel der uv- kamera die sind die da sitzen hinter dem deckeln die sind und dann hundertstel millimeter dünn da geht die tür auf,
und dann habe ich die säcke experiment meghan genannt.
Und die nächste schlussfolgerung ist dass das kommando dann sami open heißt sesam öffne dich,
also wir überlegen uns da schon ganz nette sachen und es muss auch sinn machen und gaus in göttingen ist hat also gesagt ich will,
was ist das sonnenwind und wir springen fliegen wir zu den quellen also bessere namen denke ich es ist mir jetzt nicht eingefallen und es ist es wichtig dass man bei der auswahl dann dabei ist,
das kann man ja nicht beantragen okay ich brauche forschungsgelder für die mission.
Und es braucht dann doch eine lange zeit und diese diese anträge die man dann stellen muss oder diese forschungsprojekte zu verfassen und zu planen da war's dann zweitausendelf zwölf und dann haben wir eben aktiv an der kamera.
Weiterentwickelt und darauf wollte ich nämlich auch noch hinaus dass diese kamera eine weiterentwicklung der stereokamera der technologien,
vor nichts nichts kommt also es ist ein langer sinn lange entwicklungsprozess ohne die entwicklung ohne so kein schere ohne die serie missions entwicklung keine sola pop.
Und dann kommt ja noch der arbeiter dazu.
Welche anforderungen.
Gibt es denn jetzt an die kamera ich meine stereo hat ja nun abstand zur sonne wenn man jetzt auf einmal dann auf neun sonnendurchmesser ran fliegt das sind dann doch schon ganz andere zustände.
Das stimmt also die.
Kamera das muss man deutlich trennen von den kameras die auf dem solo fliegen es ist also kein niemals ein duplikat und wir haben auch keine kamera die direkt die sonne beobachtet.
Soll nur so zur seite.
Ja und zwar haben wir argumentiert also erstmal ist es technologisch zu schwierig,
durch das hitzeschild loch zu bohren dann auf die sonne zu gucken wird auch viel zu heiß hitzeschild temperatur maximum
tausendfünfhundert grad dahinter an den radiatoren achthundert grad dahinter am körper der raumsonde zimmertemperatur und da funktionieren die instrumente und das sind in sido das sind direktoren die messen wie warm,
ist es hier wie ist das magnetfeld,
wie ist die teilchen dichte wie es die geschwindigkeit des plasma welche elektromagnetischen felder und die eine kamera die wir haben die guckt in flugrichtung,
die soll nämlich die corolla beobachten oder den sonnenwind in dem wir eintauchen mit der sonne in den nächsten minuten stunden tagen.
Also quasi so eine frontkamera in flug.
Denn ohne wie wir das von so gelernt haben ohne simultanhammer beobachtung ohne kontext messung.
Können wir die wissenschaftlichen fragestellungen nicht lösen.
Das heißt von der erde aus die beobachtung nehmen wir dazu von der sonne von den anderen satelliten aber wir haben phasen in der mission wo wir wissen wollen wo sind wir grade durchgeflogen das wollen wir im prinzip ständig wissen.
Und der arbeit ist ja so dass wir immer hoch punkten müssen ganz anders als mission prinzip als bei so stereo
wo wir die kameras auch wochenlang testen können und dann kalibrieren können und anpassen können in den
in den belichtungszeiten und dem den sequenzen die gefahren werden,
das heißt wir schicken hoch dann arbeitet arbeitet die kamera und die instrumente autonom zeichnen auf wenn wieder,
richtung erde gefunkt werden kann wird runtergebracht dann sitzen wir jetzt zurzeit da wo wir schon vier umläuft um die sonne haben sogar jetzt nach dem letzten venus vorbei flug im dezember,
sind wir im januar jetzt ende januar auf achtzehn millionen kilometer reingekommen das heißt im vergleich zu den zweiundvierzig die wir vorhaben,
enorm und es funktioniert alles und wir sitzen vor den daten und gucken.
Was war denn das spannendes gemessen und wie müssen wir die kamera vor einem einstellen für den nächsten flug um flug und dann gibt's wieder mehrere umzüge,
wo wir bei diesen achtzehn millionen kilometer abstand bleiben,
bis zum nächsten venus vorbei flug und dann schiebt sich das wieder dichter ran insgesamt kommen wir dann irgendwann nicht irgendwann zum jahr zweitausend vierundzwanzig fünfundzwanzig auf sechs millionen kilometer.
Das heißt das ding spult sich quasi,
immer wieder getriggert durch die nähe zur venus in bestimmten teil des vorbei flugs immer wieder näher an die sonne ran,
in diesem einen teil der lips fliegt aber dann entsprechend weit auch wieder heraus was wie wie weit ist denn der weiteste punkt von der sonne wenn bevor die probe dann wieder.
Ja das ist es fast erdal abstand bis null komma acht astronomische.
Also das ding fliegt jetzt quasi die ganze zeit immer so von der erde zur sonne kann man.
Ja und was ich vorhin noch erwähnen wollte wir müssen also durch die erdumlaufbahn,
und die physikalische gesetze haben wir also keine rakete,
technologisch die wo wir direkt zur sonne hinfliegen können wir würden immer den die geschwindigkeit des der erdumlaufbahn in den puls mitnehmen und deswegen brauchen wir auch eine rakete wo wir die sonne zur venus schießen können,
mit einem bestimmten schub und damals also bei der probe,
in der umsetzung wir hatten ursprünglich eine andere rakete vorgesehen aber was uns enorm geholfen hat war eben diese,
entwicklung die jetzt unter space-x gelaufen sind dadurch wurde die raketen technologie dann das hat den preis etwas gedrückt und wir konnten eben dann auf die delta heavy kommen von,
united lounge.
Also auch wenn man sich mit spezies geflogen ist hat der einfluss von space-x dafür gesorgt dass die preise ein bisschen entspannter wurden.
Ja das ist für uns günstig geworden weil das dann auch damals in die technologische entwicklung der sonne wir konnten also die dinge unterbringen,
weil wir ja immer mit masse wir haben damals tatsächlich für die kamera,
plötzlich festgestellt oh die radio wellen antennen die hängen so wie die sonne jetzt im moment zusammengebaut ist gehen die ins gesichtsfeld rein von unserer kamera,
wir möchten dies und das beobachten und dann haben wir noch was übrig gehabt um zwei weitwinkel objektive fliegen zu können.
Und dann haben wir ein problem gelöst und damals haben wir dann an den linsen die haben wir hier in deutschland mit staub beschossen um zu gucken ob er wirklich in flugrichtung,
wie so ein fahrradfahrer der ständig die insekten dann auf der sonnenbrille hat oder im auge prasselt dann auch im weltraum dieser staub der von kometen kommt oder von asteroiden und.
Dreckiger ort ist universum.
Ja der ist also prasselt in flugrichtung stärker auf diese objektive ein als wenn wir das auf der rückseite nur der haken ist auf der rückseite da hätten wir ja immer die bilder gemacht nachdem wir dadurch geflogen werden durch den korona,
durch die gebiete und wir wollen es ja vorher haben und das ist also zum beispiel der erfolg der deutschen beteiligung die zur umsetzung der.
Technologie der wiesback kamera geführt hat und wiesbaden ist also wieder ein white feed image apropo klar es gibt.
Also dass der name für diese.
Ist der name für die weitwinkelkamera und an die anderen daten kommen ja auch alle ran und die sind nach zwei nach ein paar monaten sind die für jeden zugänglich,
ganz wichtiger punkt kann es ist also keine keine geheimformel die bei uns bleibt sondern wir müssen.
Eine menge brauchen eine menge monate um die zu kalibrieren da ist ein sensor drauf der ist ein bisschen temperaturabhängig klar es ist ja nicht immer fünfundzwanzig sondern auch mal vierundzwanzig dreiundzwanzig grad,
hinter achthundert hinter tausendfünfhundert grad und das bedeutet dass jeder pixel des sensors ein anderes rauschen hat und das muss korrigiert werden und sechs monate danach sind die daten im internet also für jeden zugänglich.
Okay das heißt in dem moment wo die kalibriert und die daten fertig sind sind sie auch sofort allen zugänglich es gibt da jetzt nicht wie das üblicherweise bei mission immer war so ein dezidiertes wissenschaftlerteam wasser den erst zugriff hat.
Wir haben eine zeitspanne vorgegeben beim orbit sie noch kürzer.
Innerhalb der die daten freigegeben werden müssen natürlich gibt's ein zeitsprung und der zeitsprung resultiert aus dem wissen.
Wenn man kein wissen hat kann man die daten nicht analysieren.
Aber wir wir haben kein protektionismus das ist also doch schon eine tolle sache teamarbeit um wirklich erkenntnisse zu gewinnen.
Natürlich gibt es immer in der forschung gewisse konkurrenz mit den theorien und dann haben wir ja den den orbit gestartet im im.
Februar jetzt gerade und der ist ein bisschen unterschiedlich konzipiert sonst wird man sich ja fragen warum schießen die da zwei sondern zur sonne
der kommt also der sonne wie die helios bis auf ungefähr merkur abstand vierzig millionen kilometern besitzt aber die kameras.
Weiterentwicklung von säuren stereo die die sonne ins auge fassen und zwar aus einem abstand zu dicht wie nie zuvor und.
Er bewegt sich aus ägypten rauch auch wieder anhand von venus vorbeiflüge und ist dann.
Zwischen fünfundzwanzig und in einer verlängerten phase der mission bis dreiunddreißig grad neigung zur umlaufbahn der erde dann hat man also wirklich das erste mal kameras die,
die möglichkeit haben die polarregion der sonne zu analysieren.
Und bei einer dieser kameras bin ich beteiligt ist aber keine sonnenkarte hat das auch wieder analog zu soula probe eine weitwinkelkamera für sonnenwind und korona und aus deutschland ist der starke,
starke beitrag an vier kameras vom max-planck-institut für sonnensystem forschung.
Genau also ich denke es ist ganz angemessen nochmal so auf die besonderheit des momentes hinzuweisen also heute haben wir den neunzehnten februar zwanzig der staat von solar ist jetzt gerade mal neun tage her so ja auch nochmal fragen,
wie ging es ihnen da so ich meine die der staat moment ist doch,
muss doch jedes mal irgendwie total zerreißen so einen tag oder ist man da so sehr auf auf irgendwas konzentriert dass man das dann schon gar nicht mehr merkt aber ich meine man weiß ja wenn wenn das schiefgeht dann.
Das ist einfach jahrelange arbeit vielleicht nicht komplett für die katze aber doch zumindest weitgehend vernichtet.
Das war beim solar- der staat nicht so extrem wie beim start des voller proberaum sondern ganz einfach weil meine stelle über die voller provision finanziert wird.
Okay.
Das heißt das ist das dritte mal also damals als ich bei der esa gearbeitet habe da war es vorgesehen dass ich auf die forscher stelle für so komme in deutschland nach einem erfolgreichen start.
Also im dezember fünfundneunzig und im februar märz sechsundneunzig habe ich in deutschland.
Das heißt auch die finanzierung der okay so habe ich dann auch gleich drüber nach.
So und damals so so.
Um jetzt zu ihrer frage wieder um darauf zurückzukommen so war wann stereo war feuchte hände da war ich beim start live dabei,
bei so war ich ja nur beim kontrollzentrum und stereo cape canaveral der staat fünfzehn jahre arbeit ungefähr drin.
Ganzen tag und dann natürlich auch größeres beben das abklingt erst langsam tage danach und bei sola prob auch enorm da hängt dann auch wieder meine stelle die nähere zukunft dran.
Und da natürlich auch so ein gewisser haben möchte ich doch schon sagen gewisser erfolgsgefühl klar,
aber auch eine gewisse erschöpfung weil man ja so lange dafür gebraucht hat nicht intensiv viele viele jahre da sind wir ja wieder da wo sie wonach sie gefragt haben das kostet viel zeit.
Stimmt gedanklich natürlich auch wirklich.
Das ist ja nicht so dass man jetzt sagt okay jetzt habe ich hier ein paar stunden am tag was für die mission gemacht hat ja dinge die man sich dann.
Die einem dann doch noch durch den kopf gehen weil sie komplexer sind missions planung wird es was ängste haben wir natürlich auch immer.
Wird uns das geld gekürzt klar und dann haben wir natürlich auch den druck warum prominent zur sonne.
Warum machen wir nicht wieder eine maß mission das sind ja tatsächlich alles so fragen und klappt das technisch.
Es ist ja nicht so erstmal der staat der war ja auch im super bei beiden missionen.
Hola prob da ist die rakete die delta heavy in die siebzig meter hoch jetzt soll er orbit gestartet worden mit einer atlas fünf rakete die ist in die dreißig meter.
Hatten etwas geringeren schub das liegt daran dass man ja auch nicht so dicht rankommen muss mit dem solo ein anderes konzept hat aber deutlich mehr gewicht doppelt so schwer wie die.
Gut also beim start das ist super wir bekommen dann das sind dann die tollen sachen die man so mitmacht natürlich auf einladung von der nasa.
Wenn man dann am cape ist dann spricht man mit personen kennen die die astronauten auch noch selbst zum,
zum start gefahren haben und so wie ich auch selber astronaut noch kenne die auf dem mond waren in dem man über den sonnenwind sprechen kann.
Was eine tolle geschichte ist es gibt ja nichts besseres also wenn man eine person hat die sich auskennt und nicht alles nur gelesen hat.
Was hast du denn gestern gemacht ja ich habe meine astronauten weil sonnenwind gesprochen.
Auch beim start ist es eben eine eine super sache wenn man jetzt ein meeting hat mit personen die an der ersten stufe gearbeitet haben und so weiter denn da das ist auch der grund warum man in diesen test in diesen teams,
emissions planung so unheimlich viel dazulernen weil man dann eben kontakt hat sich direkt unterhält fragen stellen kann.
Das geht bei der videotelefonat konferenz nicht so einfach gut also start von zoll abrupt war ein enormes ereignis und ohne erfolgreichen start dann.
Ja dann hängt die stelle dran.
Die ganze arbeit die man vorher sowieso da geleistet hat und wenn es und es sieht ja im moment sehr gut aus das heißt bis zweitausendsechsundzwanzig,
läuft es bis erstmal bis wir die sechs millionen kilometer näher an die sonne erreicht haben,
dazu gehören natürlich auch dann viele verträge mit nasa und deutsche luft-und raumfahrtzentrum dass das projekt fördert.
Das heißt das war für mich der unterschied ich war natürlich super froh solar orbit auch eine beteiligung die mission ergänzt zola prob.
Sehr gut hervorragend wird neue erkenntnisse auch eben über die sonnenposition liefern.
Aber ich hatte nicht die feuchten hände ne ganz einfach.
Jetzt.
Haben wir ja im prinzip eine außergewöhnliche neue forschungsstand eigentlich was du die sonne forschung betrifft wenn man jetzt so zwei,
starke mission hat sage ich mal,
die sich gegenseitig ergänzen die alle etwas anders gelagert sind aber die beide der der sonne noch verhältnismäßig nahe kommen dazu hat man natürlich immer den bonus.
Der technologischen entwicklungen die instrumente sind mehr oder weniger auf dem stand der technik und vieles ist natürlich auch schon bekannt das heißt man kann sich jetzt eben auf die neuen mysterien konzentrieren was sind denn so die primären
forschungszentrum jetzt bei der mission zusammengenommen also,
das eine gewinnt man wahrscheinlich aus dem das angewendet man aus dem und manches ergibt sich vielleicht auch eben erst durch die kombination dieser wissenschaftlichen erkenntnisse der einzelnen mission aber welche fragestellung haben sich denn,
vielleicht jetzt schon,
neu auch ergeben aus dem bisherigen missionsfeld lauf bei der parka also der ist ja gerade mal gestartet ist er erstmal unterwegs,
wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht richtig aktiv welche frage stellung sind überhaupt noch im im raum die man,
von dem man sich vielleicht verspricht dass sie im rahmen dieser mission zumindest einer klärung näher geführt werden können was weiß man noch nicht oder was weiß man was man nicht weiß.
Apropos besucht als erste sonde oder durch fliegt als erste sonde der menschheit die atmosphäre eine.
Wenn wir dort die größen messen physikalischen größen des sonnenwind ist und der corona daraus.
Wollen wir analysieren wie die sonne wäre entsteht warum ist es so heiß warum ist es millionen grad heißt das gas was eigentlich nach den normalen physikalischen gesetzen gar nicht gehen sollte.
Wieso.
Weil es keine keinen heißeren temperaturen über der sonnenoberfläche fläche mit sichtbaren sonnenscheibe sechstausend grad geben sollte.
Das heißt die oberfläche ist sehr viel kälter als das was danach kommt.
Nun muss man unterscheiden dass das gas keine strahlung temperatur überzeugt,
also die apropo tausendfünfhundert grad bewegt sich aber in meinem millionen grad heißen plasma damit man diesen diesen widerspruch ein bisschen vermeidet also für uns ist ist wieder die frage nach dem eisen vierzehn wo kommt das her wie wird der sonnenwind überhaupt,
beschleunigt das ist eine andere frage.
Was bringt ihnen auf die dazu zu expandieren in sonnensystem wie kommt er auf die paar hundert kilometer pro sekunde die er braucht und überhaupt von der schwerkraft der sonne wegzukommen.
Wissen wir nicht dann frage zu elektrischen feldern und so weiter dann ist es so dass wir halt verschiedene theorien haben und.
Ausschließen können was nicht zutrifft.
Können wir also bisschen einmal nicht gelöst die frage also atmosphäre wo kommt die corinna her wie entsteht der sonnenwind wie entstehen energiereiche teilchen.
Es gibt zum beispiel staub bei der sonne sind alle staubteilchen sublimiert.
Das heißt verdampft durch die sonne hitze das ist auch ein großer aspekt dass man.
Schaut wie es die staub verteilung um die sonne weil wir von der erde aus immer durch den staub durchgucken und das bei der kamera jetzt nicht der fall ist und rein theoretisch,
wir haben also jetzt auch schon,
bahn gefunden von sowie die erde sich durch kennt ja jeder von den sternschnuppen von den resten von den schweifen oder von den,
von den bahnen wo sich brocken ansammeln wenn die erde durchblick gibt sternschnuppen per sein zum beispiel wir sehen in unseren bildern auch.
Bereiche von von,
sozusagen bahn wo sich der staub von kometen angesammelt hat der komet nicht selbst aber in der bahn ist mehr staub und da ist die frage wie ist jetzt diese staub verteilung.
Und dann haben wir mit der kamera was will das ansprüchen sprechen die ersten bilder die ersten ergebnisse sind ja im,
november in der zeitschrift nature veröffentlicht worden da ist besonders interessant sicherlich zu erwähnen dass man eben diese,
staub spuren gefunden hat dass man hinweise darauf hat dass dich dabei der sonne die,
der staub ganz verdampft ist es ist der staub freie zonen gibt.
Der sonnenwind komische richtungswechsel im magnetfeld erzeugt wo wir nicht wissen sind da vielleicht jetzt auf der sonne so kleines geilige phänomene die dann,
verwirbelt sind und die wir hier im größeren abstand nicht mehr sehen wird der sonnenwind ist es ein kontinuierlicher strom aber diese wirbel sprechen da sozusagen dagegen wo auch die magnetfeld richtung sich immer um,
dass der dynamische prozesse turbulenzen auftritt und die ursachen der vorgänge die wollen wir halt verstehen und jetzt,
hätten wir mit diesen variationen in den daten erstmal gar nicht gerechnet dazu gehören auch die flüsse energiereiche teilchen die wir im abstand gar nicht gar nicht beobachten können gar nicht auflösen können.
Wieder zurück zum ursprünglichen problem,
wir sind so weit weg dass wir eigentlich die wirklichen entstehung janis men nicht entschlüsseln können beim arbeiter ist es so.
Dass wir die zustands größen nicht messen vor ort wir haben aber kameras die das magnetfeld beobachten.
Was heißt zustands größen in dem zusammenhang.
Zustand größen heißt mit der probe die geschwindigkeit des sonnenwind dessen zusammensetzung des magnetfeld dazu.
Und mit dem orbit da gucken wir jetzt auf die region auf der sonne wo es erzeugt wird.
Das magnetfeld ist ja der ursprüngliche treiber was wiederum im sonnenenergien entsteht bringt uns wieder zurück an den anfang schönerweise und der auslöser dieses ganzen.
Das geht mit dem orbit mit dem magneten grafen mit den kameras.
Das heißt das ist so ein bisschen auch die die idee die die probe ist da dran die mist was geht hier überhaupt ab um im oberteil schaut man gleichzeitig zu und sagt so sieht das aus wenn es solche messwerte gibt.
Ja wo kommt es her.
Spannend wie viel abstimmung hatten also war das eigentlich von anfang an klar dass diese beiden missionen so in kombination antreten werden oder hat sich das erst so ergeben.
Ehrliche antwort es war nicht klar.
Deswegen habe ich auch ich war auch bei den anfängen dabei als der orbit konzipiert wurde und bei dem solar- bitter wollte man einfach eine nachfolge mission die die forschung weiterbringen konzipieren.
Nach so.
Also zum beispiel ist ja stereo da hat dann die die lisa gesagt nee beteiligen wir uns nicht dran obwohl die angebote bestanden und ich habe gesagt nach stereo was brauchen wir dann wir wollen ich will zur sonne hin.
Ich möchte so erprobt und die andere mission ist so ein bisschen man wollte noch dichter ran dann wollte,
alles mögliche machen da musste man sozusagen gewisse kompromisse kompromisse machen die aber auch wie bei der soll abrupt vielleicht planung auch zu einer sehr guten lösung insgesamt geführt,
haben also sie waren ursprünglich nicht.
So vorgesehen dass sie sich ergänzen aber die situation ist ausgearbeitet worden so möchte ich das formulieren.
Zu einer großartigen sache.
Das klingt für mich so ein bisschen als werden doch schon noch ein paar fragen zu beantworten es noch ist noch viel viel unbekanntes von dem man jetzt weiß dass man's nicht weiß.
Ja das problem ist mit dem messungen kommt dann wieder neue fragen ne das ist halt immer so ein.
Erstmal ist es so nicht jede frage ist richtig ne wenn ich die falsche frage stelle kriege ich auch keine antwort das andere ist nicht jeden interessiert auch das nicht so ein wo kommt der sonnenwind her da können sie ja mal.
Aber für uns ist es wichtig für die das verständnis um das entstehen von stern atmosphären überhaupt.
Nicht nur für die sonne für uns ist es fundamental weil wir leben ja quasi im sonnenwind mit der erde fürs weltraum wetter und dessen effekt.
Darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich ein bisschen nochmal hinauskommen vielleicht so zum abschluss weil.
Dieser begriff weltraum wetter ich weiß gar nicht wie lange der schon so zirkuliert aber das ist ja etwas wenn man vom wetter spricht,
dann hat es immer diese konsultation dass es einen auch irgendwie betrifft ja was interessiert mich der sonnenwind so kann,
meinetwegen kann ja der wind sein auf der sonne ist mir doch egal aber weltraum wetter was ja im
prinzip letzten endes auch nichts anderes ist als wie wie wehte der wind derzeit impliziert ja eben diese auswirkung
auf die erde und jetzt hat mir dieses was war das das ereignis wo der strom hops gegangen ist in,
in kanada und das an vielen stellen der erde gemessen werden konnte wir haben ja mittlerweile eine sehr viel.
Anfälliger sind alle sehr viel komplexere gesamt technologie mittlerweile am start auf unserem planeten satelliten,
in großer zahl die die erde umkreisen die alle irgendeiner form zusammenhängen das gps system von dem wiederum eine unmenge an dienstleistungen und system zuständen abhängt,
wie muss man sich das jetzt vorstellen wie groß,
ist der einfluss tatsächlich von der sonne nachdem was man bisher weiß was würde zum beispiel passieren
wenn man jetzt nochmal so ein carrington ereignis nochmal durchleben würde was was wovon könnte man jetzt ausgeht oder wovon kann man sicher ausgehen oder wovon kann man vielleicht ausgehen,
was dann passieren würde.
Ich möchte gern damit anfangen dass ich sage wir haben ja gerade über diese wunderbaren mission gesprochen.
Und die forschung die wir in den letzten jahrzehnten.
Durchgeführt haben die hat dazu geführt dass wir einen sprung gemacht haben von der untersuchung von solarteure gestrichen beziehungen wie es früher mal hieß gaus
zum beispiel gehen sie zurück ich sehe polarlichter und ich weiß,
muss was von der sonne vielleicht kommen ich weiß aber nicht wie es funktioniert hat sich geändert indem wir den sonnenwind wir wissen es ist der sonnenwind wir wissen dass die erde im einflussbereich des sonnenwind ist wir wissen dass es stürmischen sonnenwind gibt nämlich die,
herr option wir wissen.
Welche davon die erde beeinträchtigen können wir sind dabei es zu quantifizieren das wäre ohne diese forschung gar nicht möglich geworden das ist ein großer sprung noch immer vom erkenntnisgewinn das verursacht es und,
jetzt kann ich genau berechnen wir modellieren jetzt dinge und klar für den einzelnen sind nur wenige aspekt,
des weltraum wetters,
dazu gehören ja alle aspekte von der sonne primär sonnenwind stürmischer sonnenwind das heißt alle massenausbreitung oder sonnenstürme,
plätze energiereiche teilchen.
Das hängt einmal davon ab wo befinde ich mich wenn ich auf dem erdboden bin merke ich als normaler bürger relativ wenig davon es sei denn es wird ein großflächiger und langanhaltender stromausfall erzeugt.
Was tatsächlich schon passiert ist mehrfach.
Und da auch vorkehrungen untersuchungen getroffen werden damit nicht für eine.
Längere zeit transformator beschädigt worden werden das ist zum beispiel südafrika der fall gewesen zweitausenddrei die netze sind unterschiedlich anfällig
das würden wir merken und dann natürlich auch die ganzen dominieren effekte die damit zusammenhängen die anderen effekte des weltraum wetters zum beispiel strahlungslos belastung durch,
energiereiche teilchen die hängt davon ab wo wir uns aufhalten.
Das heißt wenn ich bin bin ich auf dem mars bin ich auf dem mond bin ich im das playstation.
Setzt sich im flugzeug auf gewissen polaren routen erfahre ich diese strahlenbelastung.
Die möchte man vermeiden ist also auch ein wichtiger aspekt und nicht nur die biologische belastung sondern auch die effekte das teilchen mit energien von megabit roden wollt,
elektronische komponenten beeinträchtigen können bis ganz zum ausfall führen können also wenn ich jetzt einen flug mache zum mars und habe eine elektronik die wird,
zerstört durch den teichen beschoss dann habe ich ein problem man möchte also doch ganz gerne,
nicht viel vielleicht andere nur einmal zu mastern möchte das wieder bei der mondlandung einmal hin und auch sicher zurück ist eine zielsetzung sollte man nicht vergessen.
Das ist also für die weiterentwicklung wichtig also einmal wollte ich darauf hinaus dass man verschiedene effekte dicht direkt spürt sondern indirekt also wenn wir einen raketenstart machen dann interessiert uns wie ist das weltraum wetter oben dazu gehört auch weltraum schrott,
was fliegt rum gibt's gerade einen sonnenstrom dann starten wir nicht nur macht natürlich nicht die wenigsten machen regelmäßig raketenstart.
Ansonsten geht es gerade ein in die reglementierung oder in die neuen gesetzgebung des flugverkehrs weil nämlich,
kommunikationssysteme beeinträchtigt werden können gps das ganze galileo durch,
sonnenstürme und dann ist es eben auch komplexer als vielleicht die meisten denken wenn man jetzt im internet da steht dann auch dafür das handy aus oder
mein gps fällt aus das kann passieren das hängt aber davon ab wo ich mich auch noch regional aufhalte also wenn ich es gibt gewisse,
gegnern auf der erde wo das magnetfeld schwächen hat und sich ein sonnenstürmen stärker auswirkt das ist die strahlenbelastung die ich an den polen führe dann konnten das ja auch zum beispiel anschaulich mit den polarlichtern vergleichen es sind ströme,
die in der oberen atmosphäre fließen hundert bis fünfhundert kilometer höhe die sehe ich sonst nur in nord skandinavien wegen des polar-licht globales aber bei starken stürmen bis nach deutschland bis runter nach spanien,
dann habe ich über mehr ströme fließen und die können natürlich induzierten das ist sichtbar das merkt.
Aber das heißt von den einzelnen strömen merkt man nichts sondern lange leitung transatlantik kabel sogar.
Öl leitung für.
Werden ja über der erde verlegt weil der sonnenwind und die oder die anschaulich die polarlichter die ströme die fließen dort induzierten.
Und das führt zu korrosion dann haben wir gesagt flugverkehr.
Zu korrosion führt das.
In den leitungen und die stand instandhaltung der leitung kostet geld.
Langfristig oder auch kurzfristig also.
Das sind langfristige folgeerscheinungen.
Okay also flackert nicht kurz und alles ist verrostet aber es schädigt sozusagen die substanz.
Ja deswegen legten blick man die über die erde mit einer gegenspannung von einigen wollt,
und dann ganze infrastruktur ganze satelliten kommunikation wir haben jetzt bei sonnenstürmen den effekt dass ich die äußere erdatmosphäre.
Ein paar hundert kilometer höhe für den weltraum wir fliegen ja dann vierhundert dann die erdnahen satelliten neunhundert kilometer höhe,
dass dort die dichte sich ändert aufgrund der einwirkung des sonnenwind ist auf das magnetfeld die magnete fähre und dann zu konvention führt und die dichte erhöht und dann gibt es zum beispiel satelliten forschungsstelle der fünf kilometern höhe verliert,
sturm neunzehnhundertneun.
Weil einfach mehr widerstand durch die atmung.
Genau genau und dann sind sie athleten dann nicht mehr da wo ich sie eigentlich hätte und dadurch verliere ich kurzfristig den kontakt.
Und dann habe ich natürlich wenn ich von dem von der kommunikation abhängig bin kommunikation ist dann auch immer navigation steuerung von schiffs navigation etc dann treten probleme auf.
Unser.
Den eigentlichen wohlstand der technologie wieder zunichte machen dann werden wir bedroht dann ist die infrastruktur betrifft das sind die dinge die alltäglich sind die wir benutzen.
Anfällig.
Das muss man eben bei einem carrington sturm berücksichtigen da gibt's berechnungen in verschiedenen ländern sollte man für deutschland auch machen gibt es sicherlich überlegungen und,
berechnungen durchzuführen wie muss ich meine infrastruktur schützen damit ich weiß da kommt ein sonnenstürme dann kann ich an der steuern.
Ist auch immer die frage wo betreibe ich mein stromnetz zum beispiel aufgrund der verschiebung der,
der lage der pole gegenüber den geographischen liegen die stromnetze in nord kanada direkt unter dem polar-licht zonen skandinavien ist das nicht so stark der fall und dann kann ich eben dort auch die fluktuation berücksichtigen bei der steuerung des netzes.
Bei den regeln des flugverkehrs und fundamental ist natürlich wiederum dass wir ja immer jetzt von wissenschafts- daten profitiert haben.
Das ist der grund wir haben kakao weltraum wettersatelliten spezifiziert wo wir auch wieder gegenstand bedarf sehen für eine neue mission,
die dann wirklich nicht sagt ok wir wollen jetzt sonnenstrom analysieren müssen wir sowieso stereo ganz würde ich sagen neue erkenntnisse geliefert über die dreidimensionalität,
wenn die erde eine stecknadel ist dann ist es nicht egal.
Es ist halt nicht so umgehen wie luftballons sondern dieser sonnenstrom kann man sich vorstellen ob ich jetzt etwas weiter südlich südlich nödlich im weltraum diese,
unwetterfront durch stoße erzeugt dann ganz andere effekte,
das haben wir mit stereo zum beispiel gelernt in der analyse von sonnenstürmen und da braucht man natürlich eine mission die einem.
Die unwetter von der sonne die sonnenstürme verfolgt von der sonne bis zur erde.
Dass man dann präzise ankunftszeiten hat nicht unnötige vorwarnungen macht.
Es gibt auch die discover mission ist auch ein kleines satellit der.
Auf diesen punkt zwischen erde und sonne rumhängt und immer so schöne,
also eigentlich die ganze zeit in den blick auf die erde richtet eigentlich eine der schönsten täglichen quellen von irgendwie,
erdbeobachtung weil ja dadurch sozusagen die sich der erde immer quasi immer im vollen sonnenlicht zwangsläufig aber,
die schaut doch auch ein bisschen in die andere richtung und nimmt dieses sonnenwind wetter auch war oder nicht.
Sonnenwind messen wir kontinuierlich mit und discover im also in dem raum bereich wo sich auch so befindet.
Aber das reicht nicht aus.
Der haken ist vom l eins sind eins komma fünf millionen kilometer klingt schon mal weit aber der sonnenwind bei der geschwindigkeit von dreihundert bis.
Einigen tausend kilometer pro sekunde braucht zwischen einer stunde und fünfzehn minuten.
Sie von vor waren zeitreichtum.
Vorwärts zeit ist zu kurz.
Was würden sie für angemessen erhalten.
Zwölf stunden vierundzwanzig stunden.
Vierundzwanzig stunden aber es ist also das licht braucht er nur acht minuten von der sonne wie lange ist denn der sonnenwind unterwegs.
Sonnenwind ist zwischen fünf tagen und etwas mehr als zwei stunden unterwegs.
Das heißt man müsste eigentlich schon sehr nah dran.
Ja aber das kann man ja auch von weiter weg weil man ja die sonne sieht dann eben diese die aufnahme die man gemacht hat von dem von der sonnenreflektion von dem kunden in massen ausbruch ist acht minuten vorher gewesen,
so lange braucht das licht dann muss ich noch die zeit überdenken bis es unten auf der erde ist.
Die ist relativ kurz da muss ich jemanden sitzen haben der ist auch gleich versteht und analysiert und dann kann ich also innerhalb von,
zwei stunden nach dem ausbruch sagen achtung.
Allein sozusagen auf der beobachtung der aktivität nicht auf einer messung eines tatsächlich daraus resultierenden windes.
Naja eine messung ist es auch weil es gibt sonnenstürme auf allen räumlichen und zeitlichen sky,
also stellen sie sich vor elf jahre da haben sie weit mehr als zehntausend sonnenstürme und von denen aber vielleicht nur fünfzig die geschwindigkeiten erreichen von mehreren tausend kilometer pro sekunde.
Das liegt so im bereich drei viertausend kilometer pro sekunde da haben wir einige die müssen dann richtung erde laufen.
Und die werden gott sei dank abgebremst auf dem weg durch weil er ja nicht leer ist weil er langsamer sonnenwind ist das haben wir auch gelernt jetzt und diese abbremsung wird modelliert.
Und da müssen wir noch wissen welches magnetfeld kommt jetzt von der sonne richtung erde damit wir diesen kurzschluss erzeugen können und das geht alles in die vorhersage ein aber diesen zeitraum hat man dann also der schnellste.
Sturm oder die kürze der kürzeste zeitliche abstand vom ausbruch zur sonne bis zur effekten meiner erde betrug vierzehn stunden bei kirchen waren siebzehn stunden das sind so die.
Zeiten deswegen minimiert ich das immer so ein bisschen sack grob gesagt zwölf stunden.
Und man kann natürlich verschiedene vorwarnungen zeiten machen also so eine sonderaktion die kommt nicht aus dem nichts also da muss ich das magnetfeld der sonne ändern,
das heißt wenn wir seitlich auf die sonne gucken dann sehen wir natürlich schon die gebiete bevor sie richtung sich richtung erde drehen und dann können wir sagen also da kommt erstmal eine woche nichts.
So grob oder in den nächsten tagen achtung und wenn wir den ausbruch sehen,
dann sehen wir ja nicht nur wo kommt er her sondern auch wie schnell ist er diese geschwindigkeit ist eine entscheidende komponente plus die magnetfeld richter und das sind die größen die wir brauchen ist also nicht einfach nur oh das ist ein phänomen,
sondern läuft auch richtung erde.
Das heißt in dem moment wo man wirklich eine eine halbwegs komplexe dauerbeobachtung der sonne auf in hinblick auf diese parameter leisten
könnte würde sich dann mehr oder weniger so eine echte wettervorhersage die dann auch,
zwölf stunden vorher schon sagte es gleich knallt dabei herauskommen dass natürlich die abwägung ne okay,
wenn man jetzt so auf der entscheider seite ist und überlegt sogar wie viel geld hauen wir jetzt für sowas raus die frage ja brauchen wir das wirklich ist das für uns ein großes problem oder sitzen wir das nicht aus und dann knallt halt mal da war es teuer das ist auch egal.
Ja da gibt's ja abschätzung die gemacht werden von versicherungen die ich kenne schweizer rück welche schäden erzeugten sonnenstrom was für sozioökonomisch folgen hat es die dann in zig milliarden,
dollar oder euro hundert milliarden euro umgerechnet werden können das geht dann eben theoretisch berechnet wieviel flugzeuge müssen am boden bleiben,
welche systeme müssen gestoppt werden welche folgen hat das ganze was mit lahmgelegt.
Beziehungsweise wie viele würde man am boden halten damit sie nicht oben schaden nehmen oder weil man nicht die kommunikation nicht sicherstellen kann oder wenn man irgendwie angst hat dass was passiert.
Also was ist der eigentliche schaden es schadet ja nicht dass alle flugzeuge runterfallen sondern schaden ist ja nur dass man vorsichtig sein will und deswegen.
Das nicht macht dann entsteht entsteht ja der schaden sozusagen eigentlich erst durch die warnung.
Na ja gut man kann also satelliten ausfällen vorbeugen die satelliten kosten viel geld man kann menschen schützen das auch ein elementares ziel ist zum beispiel indem man nehmen sie ein flugzeug.
Über die bei hohen breiten wir sagen dann worst case lautere schwangere frauen an bord.
Möchte man vermeiden.
Die strahlenbelastung.
Die strahlenbelastung ja und die tritt nicht zum beispiel auch wenn ich jetzt von,
frankfurt nach london fliege sondern ich muss sagen wir frankfurt nach san francisco oder sowas dann komme ich in bereiche rein wo ich eine erhöhte strahlenbelastung habe die man abschätzen dann einmal röntgen entspricht aber,
für das personal und unter gewissen umständen natürlich wenig zuträglich ist und wir sind gerade dabei international zivile aviation organisation das ist standards gibt fürs weltraum wetter in den letzten jahren hat,
ausfälle des schwedischen flug radars gegeben da ist einfach sonnenstrahlung radio wellen bereich in die randale anlagen gekommen und hat die blind gemacht.
Für welchen zeitraum.
Für den zeitraum von eineinhalb stunden bei dem letzten großen sonnenstrom zweitausenddrei hat man vierundzwanzig stunden eine störung des,
flughafen in europa da hatten wir sechzig flieger die am boden geblieben sind dann haben wir notfallsysteme satelliten.
Die beeinträchtigt werden wie gesagt die kommunikation navigationssysteme.
Kampagnen werden hinfällig die gemacht werden wenn man es nicht weiß.
Wie gesagt also zum beispiel gab es vor zwei jahren kropp,
den sonnenstrom und wenn man sich jetzt auskennt im flugverkehr man kann ja auch die bei der heutigen technologie die flugrouten abrufen sind ja,
empfänger am boden genug in gewissen gegenden dann sieht man also kann man also sagen auf der karte da ist ein flieger in zehntausend zwölftausend metern höhe jetzt weiß da hatten sonnenstunden nach stattgefunden kann man also sehen dass die flughöhe reduziert,
reduktion heißt höhere treibstoffverbrauch,
und durch die reduktion der höhe kommt aber wird die strahlenbelastung ganz immens reduziert ob sie jetzt zwei kilometer haben also die,
atmosphäre ist schon ein guter absorber und da kann man also direkt nachvollziehen wie viele flugzeuge haben die höhe nicht verändert und dann sieht man es sind weniger,
flugzeuge plötzlich in der gleichen höhe da und daran arbeitet man dass man jetzt keine unnützen vorhersagen dass man aber das thema einarbeitet zu viel ich weiß gibt es amerikanische airlines die das,
traumwetter auch wie wetter drin haben in ihren warnung und dann ist natürlich die frage was bei so einem großen.
Schon so ein super genau wie dem carrington ereignis passiert da haben wir ja genug erfahrung mit solchen szenarien wie fukushima und,
es kann dann durchaus dinge passieren sodass man sich wappnen muss natürlich auch.
Die zunehmende nutzung des erdnahen weltraum angeht es fliegt halt viel rum man muss wissen wo es fliegt.
Es gibt ja weltraum schrott.
Das ist so eine unvorhergesehene absenkung einer flugbahn eines satelliten kann dann halt dann schnell auch mal auf kollisionskurs bringen und wenn man dann ausgerechnet in dem moment nicht steuerbar ist dann ist gar nicht so schön.
Na da trifft der begriff aus der bahn geworfen ziemlich.
Gut das war ein umfangreicher flug durchs all auf.
Ja vielen dank fürs zuhören hier auch bei raum zeit.